Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a video or a social media post or a flyer, maybe even a video, to some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates, generative AI and real-time
Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to the rest is history.com and join the club. That is the rest is history.com. This episode is presented by Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. What does that mean? Well, say you need to make a presentation or a video or a social media post or a flyer, maybe even a video, to some, certainly to me, that sounds intimidating. But Tom, with Adobe Express's intuitive features like templates, generative AI and real-time|||感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告收听、提前解锁系列内容，并成为我们备受喜爱的聊天社区会员，请访问 theredishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 theredishistory.com。本期节目由 Adobe Express 赞助播出，这是一款快捷、简单、可创作一切的应用。这是什么意思呢？嗯，假设你需要做一个演示文稿、视频、社交媒体帖子或传单，甚至可能是一个视频，对某些人来说，当然对我也一样，这听起来让人望而生畏。但是，汤姆，凭借 Adobe Express 直观的功能，如模板、生成式人工智能和实时
collaboration, it has never been easier. Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. Click or tap the banner to try it for free. free or search Adobe Express in the app store. It's Rona Week. Now until Wednesday, and the best part, we're ready to help you extend your summer. You know the saying the grass is always greener on the other side? Well, this summer, make sure it's your side of the lawn. Head to Rona today for 5.2 kilograms of Scott's Turf Builder Fall Lawn Fertilizer at only 1499. Build it right, build it Rona. Conditions of
collaboration, it has never been easier. Adobe Express, the quick and easy create-anything app. Click or tap the banner to try it for free. free or search Adobe Express in the app store. It's Rona Week. Now until Wednesday, and the best part, we're ready to help you extend your summer. You know the saying the grass is always greener on the other side? Well, this summer, make sure it's your side of the lawn. Head to Rona today for 5.2 kilograms of Scott's Turf Builder Fall Lawn Fertilizer at only 1499. Build it right, build it Rona. Conditions of|||协作，这一切从未如此简单。Adobe Express，这款快捷、简单、万物皆可创作的应用。点击或轻触横幅即可免费试用，或在应用商店搜索 Adobe Express。现在是 Rona 周。从现在到周三，最棒的是，我们随时准备帮您延长夏日时光。你知道“邻家的草总是更绿”这句俗语吗？那么，今年夏天，确保你这边的草坪才是最绿的。今天就前往 Rona 购买 5.2 公斤装的思葛 (Scott's) 秋季草坪肥料，仅售 14.99。建造正确，首选 Rona。条件
Live. Details in store and more offers at rona.ca. General Jophe was now developing his plan. We hung on his every word. We saw as he evoked it the immense battlefield over which the core, drawn by the magnet of his will, were moving like pieces of intricate machinery until they clicked into their appointed places. We saw trains in long processions laboring under the weight of their human freight, great piles of shells mounting up by the sides of the ready and silent guns.
Live. Details in store and more offers at rona.ca. General Jophe was now developing his plan. We hung on his every word. We saw as he evoked it the immense battlefield over which the core, drawn by the magnet of his will, were moving like pieces of intricate machinery until they clicked into their appointed places. We saw trains in long processions laboring under the weight of their human freight, great piles of shells mounting up by the sides of the ready and silent guns.|||适用。详情见店内，更多优惠请访问 rona.ca。霞飞（Joffre）将军当时正在制定他的计划。我们倾听他的每一句话。当他勾勒出那幅画面时，我们仿佛看到了那片广袤的战场，在犹如磁石般的意志力的牵引下，各个军团宛如精密机械的零件般移动，直到严丝合缝地嵌入各自预定的位置。我们看到一列列长长的火车承载着如山的负荷艰难前行，成堆的炮弹在蓄势待发却又沉默的火炮旁堆积如山。
And all this was taking place behind a veil so thin and tenuous that none could perceive it, but through which no German appeared able to see. yet Joffre seemed to be pointing the Germans out to us, blundering blindly on, hastening to their fate, their huge, massive, dusty columns rushing towards the precipice over which they would soon be rolling. As a prophet, he was heard with absolute faith. We were listening to the story of the victory of the man, and we absolutely believed. Reminiscences there of a crucial exchange on the 5th of September 1914 from Edward Spears, who was a British liaison officer with the French army, and I suppose specifically with
And all this was taking place behind a veil so thin and tenuous that none could perceive it, but through which no German appeared able to see. yet Joffre seemed to be pointing the Germans out to us, blundering blindly on, hastening to their fate, their huge, massive, dusty columns rushing towards the precipice over which they would soon be rolling. As a prophet, he was heard with absolute faith. We were listening to the story of the victory of the man, and we absolutely believed. Reminiscences there of a crucial exchange on the 5th of September 1914 from Edward Spears, who was a British liaison officer with the French army, and I suppose specifically with|||而这一切都发生在一层薄如蝉翼的面纱背后，无人能够察觉，但德国人似乎也无法透过它看清真相。然而，霞飞却仿佛在向我们指出德国人的所在，他们盲目地跌跌撞撞，奔向自己的命运，那些庞大、厚重、满身尘土的纵队正冲向他们即将翻滚而下的悬崖。作为一位先知，他的话语得到了绝对的信仰。我们当时在聆听关于人类胜利的故事，我们对此深信不疑。以上是1914年9月5日关键交流的回忆，讲述者是爱德华·斯皮尔斯（Edward Spears），他当时是英国派驻法国军队的联络官，我想具体来说是派驻
General Joffre, the commander of the French army. And this is a decisive moment in the history of the First World War and therefore the entire 20th century, because it is when Joseph Joffre is outlining his plan to save Paris, to save France, and to save the entire Allied war project in the face of what many of the Allies had come to fear was an irresistible German onslaught. Yeah, it's an incredible scene, Tom. And actually, we'll come back to it a bit later, this exchange when Joff outlines his plan. So we're into the third episode of this epic series, and maybe we should remind ourselves and our listeners where we've got to. And a terrible danger in which the Allies now find themselves. So the war has been going, depending when
General Joffre, the commander of the French army. And this is a decisive moment in the history of the First World War and therefore the entire 20th century, because it is when Joseph Joffre is outlining his plan to save Paris, to save France, and to save the entire Allied war project in the face of what many of the Allies had come to fear was an irresistible German onslaught. Yeah, it's an incredible scene, Tom. And actually, we'll come back to it a bit later, this exchange when Joff outlines his plan. So we're into the third episode of this epic series, and maybe we should remind ourselves and our listeners where we've got to. And a terrible danger in which the Allies now find themselves. So the war has been going, depending when|||法国军队总司令霞飞将军的联络官。这是第一次世界大战乃至整个20世纪历史上的一个决定性时刻，因为正是在这个时候，约瑟夫·霞飞（Joseph Joffre）正在阐述他的计划，以拯救巴黎、拯救法国，并拯救整个盟军的战争大计，当时许多盟军成员已经开始担心德国人的猛烈攻势是不可阻挡的。是的，这是一个令人难以置信的场景，汤姆。事实上，我们稍后会回到这个话题，也就是霞飞阐述其计划的这次交流。我们已经进入了这个史诗般系列的第三集，也许我们应该提醒自己和听众，我们目前进展到了哪一步。以及盟军现在所处的巨大危险之中。所以这场战争一直在进行，取决于你从什么时候开始算起
you date it from, for exactly a month. I know you use the Austrian dating time, but let's keep you on your toes. And on the Western Front, the Germans have swept through Belgium and they've swept through northern France. They've taken Brussels. They've absolutely obliterated the French in the Battle of the Frontiers. They've driven the British back at Mons and at Le Cateau. On the 30th of August, with the Germans closing in on Paris and the city preparing for a siege, A million refugees on the move, the French had announced that they were going to, the government was going to abandon Paris for Bordeaux. The next day, we talked about this at the end of the last episode, Sir John French, the British commander telegraphs London, asking for permission to abandon Paris and to fall back west of the River Sen. And what follows is one of the great turnarounds, one of the great comebacks in modern history.
you date it from, for exactly a month. I know you use the Austrian dating time, but let's keep you on your toes. And on the Western Front, the Germans have swept through Belgium and they've swept through northern France. They've taken Brussels. They've absolutely obliterated the French in the Battle of the Frontiers. They've driven the British back at Mons and at Le Cateau. On the 30th of August, with the Germans closing in on Paris and the city preparing for a siege, A million refugees on the move, the French had announced that they were going to, the government was going to abandon Paris for Bordeaux. The next day, we talked about this at the end of the last episode, Sir John French, the British commander telegraphs London, asking for permission to abandon Paris and to fall back west of the River Sen. And what follows is one of the great turnarounds, one of the great comebacks in modern history.|||刚好一个月。我知道你使用的是奥地利的时间计算法，不过我们得让你保持警惕。在西线，德国人已经席卷了比利时，席卷了法国北部。他们攻占了布鲁塞尔。他们在边界战役中彻底消灭了法军。他们在蒙斯（Mons）和勒卡托（Le Cateau）将英军击退。8月30日，随着德军逼近巴黎，这座城市正准备迎接围城，数百万难民在流离失所，法国政府宣布他们将放弃巴黎，迁往波尔多。第二天，我们在上一集的结尾讨论过这件事，英国指挥官约翰·弗伦奇（Sir John French）爵士给伦敦拍了电报，请求批准放弃巴黎，并撤退到塞纳河以西。随之而来的是现代历史上最伟大的扭转乾坤、最伟大的东山再起之一。
So it's gone down in legend, I suppose, as the miracle on the man. Numbers alone are mind-boggling. We've done a lot of battles on our show, you know, the Battle of Can I or the Battle of Agincourt or whatever. But the Marn, you know, it defies the imagination. You're talking about a million Germans, a million Frenchman, are slightly smaller, I have to say, contingent to Britain. So about 125,000. But still very important. I mean, we want that put on the record. Transformational, I think, Thomas. It's quality, not quantity. Exactly. And the future. Europe is at stake, right? Because if the Germans win and if they take Paris, the story of
So it's gone down in legend, I suppose, as the miracle on the man. Numbers alone are mind-boggling. We've done a lot of battles on our show, you know, the Battle of Can I or the Battle of Agincourt or whatever. But the Marn, you know, it defies the imagination. You're talking about a million Germans, a million Frenchman, are slightly smaller, I have to say, contingent to Britain. So about 125,000. But still very important. I mean, we want that put on the record. Transformational, I think, Thomas. It's quality, not quantity. Exactly. And the future. Europe is at stake, right? Because if the Germans win and if they take Paris, the story of|||因此，我想它作为“马恩河奇迹”载入了史册。单看数字就令人头皮发麻。我们在节目中讲过很多战役，你知道的，比如坎尼会战、阿金库尔战役等等。但马恩河战役，你知道的，这简直超出了想象。你说的是一百万德国人，一百万法国人，英国派出的分遣队要稍微少一点，我必须得说。大约有 12,5000 人。但依然非常重要。我的意思是，我们要把这一点记录在案。我认为这是具有变革意义的，托马斯。质量胜过数量。确实如此。还有未来。欧洲正处于危急关头，对吧？因为如果德国人获胜，如果他们攻占了巴黎，那么
the First World War, and indeed of the 20th century, not just in Europe, but around the world, it's completely different. Absolutely. Because, of course, there is a sense in which this is a dress rehearsal, what will happen in 1940. And that perhaps is the measure of the miracle of the man. Imagine the Blitzkrieg, the British withdrawing to Dunkirk, the French government fleeing to Bordeaux, and then it is stopped. Yes. That is the scale of what. happens here it is exactly so actually you mentioned um that it's quality not quantity that matters so why don't we start with the british yeah clearly the most important players in this story with their minuscule numbers so sir john french had sent that telegram to london to herbert henry
the First World War, and indeed of the 20th century, not just in Europe, but around the world, it's completely different. Absolutely. Because, of course, there is a sense in which this is a dress rehearsal, what will happen in 1940. And that perhaps is the measure of the miracle of the man. Imagine the Blitzkrieg, the British withdrawing to Dunkirk, the French government fleeing to Bordeaux, and then it is stopped. Yes. That is the scale of what. happens here it is exactly so actually you mentioned um that it's quality not quantity that matters so why don't we start with the british yeah clearly the most important players in this story with their minuscule numbers so sir john french had sent that telegram to london to herbert henry|||第一次世界大战的历史，乃至整个20世纪的历史，不仅仅是在欧洲，而是在全世界，都将彻底改变。绝对如此。因为从某种意义上说，这可以说是1940年事件的一次彩排。这或许正是马恩河奇迹的尺度所在。想象一下闪电战，英军撤退到敦刻尔克，法国政府逃亡波尔多，然后这一切被阻止了。是的。这就是这里发生的事情的规模。完全如此。事实上，你提到过……嗯，起决定作用的是质量而不是数量，那我们为什么不从英国人开始讲起呢？是的，他们在这场故事中显然是最重要的参与者，尽管人数微乎其微。所以约翰·弗伦奇爵士给伦敦发了那封电报，发给了赫伯特·亨利
asquith's cabinet um and they gathered to discuss it at midnight on the 31st of august they were really they were asked with he's not out playing bridge or he's probably played bridge earlier in the evening writing letters to love letters or anything i like to think he's done that in the evening. He's probably had a few drink, a few sharpeners before the meeting. Anyway, they're really shocked to get this message. And now they could have agreed with Sir John French. The cabinet had already talked kind of hypothetically about how they could withdraw the British Expeditionary Force, the BEF, via the channel ports. Instead, at this meeting, they say, no, we will stand by the French, we'll basically double down on our strategy.
asquith's cabinet um and they gathered to discuss it at midnight on the 31st of august they were really they were asked with he's not out playing bridge or he's probably played bridge earlier in the evening writing letters to love letters or anything i like to think he's done that in the evening. He's probably had a few drink, a few sharpeners before the meeting. Anyway, they're really shocked to get this message. And now they could have agreed with Sir John French. The cabinet had already talked kind of hypothetically about how they could withdraw the British Expeditionary Force, the BEF, via the channel ports. Instead, at this meeting, they say, no, we will stand by the French, we'll basically double down on our strategy.|||阿斯奎斯的内阁，嗯，他们在8月31日午夜聚集在一起讨论这件事，他们真的……阿斯奎斯当时不在外面打桥牌，或者他可能在傍晚早些时候打过桥牌，写写情书什么的，我愿意相信他在傍晚时分做了这些。开会前他可能喝了几杯酒，提神醒脑。总之，收到这个消息他们感到非常震惊。他们本可以同意约翰·弗伦奇爵士的意见。内阁此前已经就如何通过海峡港口撤离英国远征军（BEF）进行了某种假设性的讨论。相反，在这次会议上，他们表示，不，我们要支持法国人，我们基本上要在我们的战略上加倍下注。
and we're actually going to send the Secretary of State for War, who we've talked about a little bit earlier on, Field Marshal Kitchener, to steady Sir John French's nerve. The most British military moustache of all time. Yes, your country needs you. You know, Kitchener is a walking poster or a walking recruitment poster. So Kitchener left overnight. He reached Paris the next day.
and we're actually going to send the Secretary of State for War, who we've talked about a little bit earlier on, Field Marshal Kitchener, to steady Sir John French's nerve. The most British military moustache of all time. Yes, your country needs you. You know, Kitchener is a walking poster or a walking recruitment poster. So Kitchener left overnight. He reached Paris the next day.|||而且我们实际上要派遣战争大臣——我们之前稍微提到过他——陆军元帅基钦那（Kitchener），去稳定约翰·弗伦奇爵士的军心。历史上最具英国军事风格的胡子。是的，你的国家需要你。你知道的，基钦那就像是一个会走路的海报，或者说是一个会走路的征兵海报。于是基钦那连夜出发。他第二天抵达了巴黎。
He went to the British embassy and basically summoned Sir John French to meet him. And he says to Sir John French, none of this talk about withdrawal. You will stay in the line and you will work with your French comrades. And French hates him, doesn't he? French hates Kitchener and vice versa. He hates various groups of people.
He went to the british embassy and basically summoned Sir John French to meet him. And he says to Sir John French, none of this talk about withdrawal. You will stay in the line and you will work with your French comrades. And French hates him, doesn't he? French hates Kitchener and vice versa. He hates various groups of people.|||他去了英国大使馆，基本上是召见约翰·弗伦奇来见他。他对约翰·弗伦奇说，不要再谈什么撤退了。你得留在防线上，和你的法国战友并肩作战。弗伦奇恨透了他，对吧？弗伦奇讨厌基钦那，反之亦然。他讨厌各种各样的人。
Kitchener is one of them and the French are another. And he's very resentful this time because Kitchener is wearing his uniform of a field marshal. Yes. And French feels that this is poor form. For reasons I'm not, I don't entirely understand. It's poor form, I think,
Kitchener is one of them and the French are another. And he's very resentful this time because Kitchener is wearing his uniform of a field marshal. Yes. And French feels that this is poor form. For reasons I'm not, I don't entirely understand. It's poor form, I think,|||基钦那是其中之一，法国人是另一个。这一次他非常怨恨，因为基钦那穿着陆军元帅的制服。是的。弗伦奇觉得这很不礼貌。出于某些我并不是完全理解的原因。我认为这很不礼貌，
because Kitchener is there in a civilian capacity. Yes, because he's the Secretary of State for defence. So he's wearing his uniform performatively in order to intimidate Sojourn French, and Sir John French knows exactly what he's doing. And he's always enraged, isn't he, Sir John French? He's about florid, about to explode. Well, he's got this tight cavalryman's kind of stock around his neck, hasn't it? So it's constantly being strangled.
because Kitchener is there in a civilian capacity. Yes, because he's the Secretary of State for defence. So he's wearing his uniform performatively in order to intimidate Sojourn French, and Sir John French knows exactly what he's doing. And he's always enraged, isn't he, Sir John French? He's about florid, about to explode. Well, he's got this tight cavalryman's kind of stock around his neck, hasn't it? So it's constantly being strangled.|||因为基钦那是以文职身份去的。是的，因为他是国防大臣。所以他穿着制服纯粹是做给别人看的，为了恐吓约翰·弗伦奇爵士，而约翰·弗伦奇对他的意图心知肚明。而且约翰·弗伦奇总是怒不可遏，不是吗？他气得满脸通红，快要爆炸了。嗯，他的脖子上系着那种紧紧的骑兵领带，不是吗？所以他感觉自己一直在被勒住。
Folds of purple flesh, quivering with rage. Do you know what? And later in this series, we have some more excellent generals on the eastern front with enormous moustaches, and one of them's got emphysema and another one that's got asthma. So basically, assume at any point than none of the generals can breathe. Right, so that's what's happened to the British. Now, what about the French?
Folds of purple flesh, quivering with rage. Do you know what? And later in this series, we have some more excellent generals on the eastern front with enormous moustaches, and one of them's got emphysema and another one that's got asthma. So basically, assume at any point than none of the generals can breathe. Right, so that's what's happened to the British. Now, what about the French?|||紫红色的皮肉层层叠叠，气得浑身发抖。你知道吗？在这个系列的后面，我们在东线还会看到更多优秀的将军，他们留着巨大的胡子，其中一个患有肺气肿，另一个患有哮喘。所以基本上，随时都可以假设没有一个将军能喘过气来。好啦，这就是英国方面的情况。那么，法国方面呢？
The French government has basically appointed a veteran general called Joseph Galliani as the military governor of Paris. So Galliani, like every single commander in this story, that would be ill. Yeah, he's really ill and he just seems like the wrong person. So he's 66 years old, his wife has just died and he's severely ill with prostate cancer.
The French government has basically appointed a veteran general called Joseph Galliani as the military governor of Paris. So Galliani, like every single commander in this story, that would be ill. Yeah, he's really ill and he just seems like the wrong person. So he's 66 years old, his wife has just died and he's severely ill with prostate cancer.|||法国政府基本上任命了一位名叫约瑟夫·加利埃尼（Joseph Galliani）的老将军担任巴黎军事总督。所以加利埃尼，就像这个故事中的每一位指挥官一样，身体都有病。是的，他病得很重，而且看起来就像是个错误的人选。他今年66岁，妻子刚刚去世，并患有严重的前列腺癌。
Lloyd George, the British Chancellor, met him around this time and said he looked, quote, sallow, shrunken and haunted. Death seemed to be chasing the particles of life out of his veins. God, that's not what you want. A man charged with the defence of Paris. But, you know, he does, he's amazing. So he absolutely throws himself into this. He says, this is going to be my last mission for my country.
Lloyd George, the British Chancellor, met him around this time and said he looked, quote, sallow, shrunken and haunted. Death seemed to be chasing the particles of life out of his veins. God, that's not what you want. A man charged with the defence of Paris. But, you know, he does, he's amazing. So he absolutely throws himself into this. He says, this is going to be my last mission for my country.|||英国财政大臣劳合·乔治（Lloyd George）大约在这个时候见了他，并说他看起来“面色惨白、日渐消瘦、神情恍惚。死神似乎正在将他血管里的生命微粒驱赶出去。”天哪，这可不是你想要的样子。一个肩负巴黎防务重任的人。但是，你知道的，他确实做到了，他太了不起了。所以他全身心地投入到了这项工作中。他说，这将是我为祖国执行的最后一次任务。
Well, Dominic, he had fought at Sudan, hadn't he? And he'd been a German prisoner of war. So he kind of knows what the stakes are in a visceral manner. This is personal for him, right? And he says, let's turn Paris into an armed camp, we will mobilize every last resource, we will fight to the last man. And he issues this brilliantly terse proclamation to the people of Paris,
Well, Dominic, he had fought at Sudan, hadn't he? And he'd been a German prisoner of war. So he kind of knows what the stakes are in a visceral manner. This is personal for him, right? And he says, let's turn Paris into an armed camp, we will mobilize every last resource, we will fight to the last man. And he issues this brilliantly terse proclamation to the people of Paris,|||好吧，多米尼克，他曾在色当作战，不是吗？他还当过德国的战俘。所以他对这其中的利害关系有着一种切身的体会。这对他是私事，对吧？他说，让我们把巴黎变成一个武装军营，我们要动员最后一点资源，我们要战至最后一个人。他向巴黎人民发布了一份极其简练的公告，
which reads as follows, Residents of Paris, I have received the mandate to defend Paris against the invader. This mandate, I shall carry out to the end. So it's not exactly d'Anton. No, but I like that. I think the very, the conciseness of it is actually quite reassuring. This is what we're going to do.
which reads as follows, Residents of Paris, I have received the mandate to defend Paris against the invader. This mandate, I shall carry out to the end. So it's not exactly d'Anton. No, but I like that. I think the very, the conciseness of it is actually quite reassuring. This is what we're going to do.|||内容如下：“巴黎的居民们，我已接受了保卫巴黎抵御侵略者的使命。这一使命，我必将执行到底。”这倒不完全是丹东的风格。不，但我喜欢这样。我认为这种极度的简洁其实相当令人安心。这就是我们要做的。
I'm going to do it. End of story. Now, the slight unmistfortune is that, like, all commanders in the First World War, he and Joff have a very tense relationship. Are there any generals who like each other? Hindenburg and Ludendorf, the great bromance that we'll be covering in a future episode. I think there's a good, there's a scope. I'd like to see a detective series. Solving crimes in East Prussia.
I'm going to do it. End of story. Now, the slight unmistfortune is that, like, all commanders in the First World War, he and Joff have a very tense relationship. Are there any generals who like each other? Hindenburg and Ludendorf, the great bromance that we'll be covering in a future episode. I think there's a good, there's a scope. I'd like to see a detective series. Solving crimes in East Prussia.|||我要把它完成。故事结束。现在，略微有些不幸的是，就像第一次世界大战中的所有指挥官一样，他和霞飞的关系非常紧张。有没有哪个将军是互相喜欢的？兴登堡和鲁登道夫，我们将在以后的节目中讲到的伟大的兄弟情。我觉得这很有看点，有发挥的空间。我想看一部侦探剧。在东普鲁士侦破案件。
Will Ferrell and John C. Riley play Hindenberg and Luton. Oh, Hindi! What are you doing? There's been a murder in a country house in Alenstein in East Prussia. Well, actually, but is it a murder? Is it a slapstick comedy? It's like Bergerac, I think. I think it's like Bergerac or something like that.
Will Ferrell and John C. Riley play Hindenberg and Luton. Oh, Hindi! What are you doing? There's been a murder in a country house in Alenstein in East Prussia. Well, actually, but is it a murder? Is it a slapstick comedy? It's like Bergerac, I think. I think it's like Bergerac or something like that.|||威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）和约翰·C·赖利（John C. Riley）饰演兴登堡和鲁登道夫。哦，欣迪！你在干什么？东普鲁士阿伦施泰因的一栋乡间别墅里发生了一起谋杀案。嗯，实际上，但这真的是谋杀吗？这是一部闹剧喜剧吗？我觉得它就像《伯杰拉克》（Bergerac）。我觉得它有点像《伯杰拉克》或者类似的剧。
I'm thinking dumb and dumber. Now, I'm doing character-intuitive casting, you see. I think it's cozy Sunday night. The BBC has spent a lot of money bringing in Hollywood stars. Come on, we've got to get back to the story, Tom. This is mad. Okay, okay. All right.
I'm thinking dumb and dumber. Now, I'm doing character-intuitive casting, you see. I think it's cozy Sunday night. The BBC has spent a lot of money bringing in Hollywood stars. Come on, we've got to get back to the story, Tom. This is mad. Okay, okay. All right.|||我想到的是《阿呆与阿瓜》。现在，我在做凭直觉的角色选角，你看。我觉得这是一个温馨的周日夜晚。BBC花了大笔资金请来了好莱坞明星。好了，我们得回到正题上来，汤姆。这太疯狂了。好吧，好吧。行吧。
Gelliani and Jof, before the war, Gelliani had been offered the job, Joff's job, Supreme Commander of the French Army, and because of his health, he turned it down. And he went to Joff, who'd once been one of his officers. Galliani, even though Joffre had been kind of one of his protégés, he now has a very low opinion of Joff.
Gelliani and Jof, before the war, Gelliani had been offered the job, Joff's job, Supreme Commander of the French Army, and because of his health, he turned it down. And he went to Joff, who'd once been one of his officers. Galliani, even though Joffre had been kind of one of his protégés, he now has a very low opinion of Joff.|||加利埃尼和霞飞，在战前，加利埃尼曾被提供过这个职位，也就是霞飞的职位——法军总司令，但由于健康原因，他拒绝了。他去找了霞飞，后者曾是他的军官之一。加利埃尼，尽管霞飞曾某种程度上是他的门生，但他现在对霞飞的评价非常低。
He saw him out walking or something in the Baud de Boulogne, and he wrote in his diary, how fat and heavy Joff is, he will hardly last out his three years. I mean, there's rich coming from him. Yeah. Meanwhile, Joph knows this, and he refuses to have Galeigh at his headquarters. He says to his
He saw him out walking or something in the Baud de Boulogne, and he wrote in his diary, how fat and heavy Joff is, he will hardly last out his three years. I mean, there's rich coming from him. Yeah. Meanwhile, Joph knows this, and he refuses to have Galeigh at his headquarters. He says to his|||他在布洛涅森林散步时看到了霞飞，他在日记中写道：“霞飞是多么肥胖沉重啊，他恐怕很难撑过这三年。”我的天，这话从他嘴里说出来可真够讽刺的。是的。与此同时，霞飞知道了这一点，他拒绝让加利埃尼出现在他的总部。他对他的
AIDS. I can't stand him. He's always wound me up. I suppose Galeini could say, in reply, that Joffa so far has had a shocker of a war. I mean, he's basically wiped out half the French army. He has. For nothing. Jophras had a very poor start of the war. He's basically killed all his men with this mad plan. Max Hastings points out quite rightly, he says if Jophrer basically died of a heart attack on the 1st of September, which is what Gellini expects at any moment, then history would remember him only as a bungler and a butcher. However, Jophe has one big thing in his favour. He never, ever loses his call because he's so large and he's always eating these enormous lunches. He's very relaxed. So everybody else is completely panicking. And he's actually just
AIDS. I can n't stand him. He's always wound me up. I suppose Galeini could say, in reply, that Joffa so far has had a shocker of a war. I mean, he's basically wiped out half the French army. He has. For nothing. Jophras had a very poor start of the war. He's basically killed all his men with this mad plan. Max Hastings points out quite rightly, he says if Jophrer basically died of a heart attack on the 1st of September, which is what Gellini expects at any moment, then history would remember him only as a bungler and a butcher. However, Jophe has one big thing in his favour. He never, ever loses his call because he's so large and he's always eating these enormous lunches. He's very relaxed. So everybody else is completely panicking. And he's actually just|||助手说。我简直受够他了。他总是惹我生气。我想加利埃尼可以反驳说，到目前为止，霞飞打了一场糟糕透顶的战争。我的意思是，他基本上消灭了一半的法军。确实如此。而且毫无意义。霞飞在战争刚开始时表现极差。他用这个疯狂的计划基本上害死了他所有的手下。马克斯·黑斯廷斯（Max Hastings）非常正确地指出，他说如果霞飞在9月1日因心脏病发作去世——这也是加利埃尼随时都在期待的事，那么历史只会记住他是一个庸碌无能的笨蛋和屠夫。然而，霞飞有一个巨大的优势。他从不、从来不会失去冷静，因为他体型庞大，而且总是享用着丰盛的午餐。他非常放松。所以其他所有人都惊慌失措的时候。而他实际上只是
been sitting in silence thinking. And to quote Max Hastings, that's an excellent line. His unbelievable calm is about to transfer him from, quote, abattoir superintendent to allied saviour. So first of all, he says, right, I'm going to sack up all my office. Like, it's basically their fault. So among them, he sacks that guy, Longerzac, who we talked about last time, the man from Guadeloupe. So his crime is to have been right?
been sitting in silence thinking. And to quote Max Hastings, that's an excellent line. His unbelievable calm is about to transfer him from, quote, abattoir superintendent to allied saviour. So first of all, he says, right, I'm going to sack up all my office. Like, it's basically their fault. So among them, he sacks that guy, Longerzac, who we talked about last time, the man from Guadeloupe. So his crime is to have been right?|||坐在那里默默地思考。引用马克斯·黑斯廷斯的话，这是一句绝妙台词。他那难以置信的平静即将把他从“屠宰场主管”转变为“盟军的救世主”。所以首先，他说，好啦，我要解雇我所有的手下。就好像，这基本上是他们的错。所以在他们当中，他解雇了那个家伙，朗格扎克（Longerzac），我们上次谈到过他，那个来自瓜德罗普的人。所以他的罪过就是——曾经是对的？
Yes, exactly. He's been right about everything, but Joff says, basically, you lot are all tainted by failure. You've got to go. And actually, I think that's, as it turns out, a good call. So he brings in a lot of new blood
Yes, exactly. He's been right about everything, but Joff says, basically, you lot are all tainted by failure. You've got to go. And actually, I think that's, as it turns out, a good call. So he brings in a lot of new blood|||是的，完全正确。他每件事都说对了，但霞飞却说，基本上，你们这群人都被失败玷污了。你们必须走人。事实上，我认为事后证明这是一个明智的决定。所以他引入了大量的新鲜血液，
who are basically very energetic and desperate to prove themselves. But also, Jophe sees something that most people have completely missed. Most people at this point assume the Germans are going to win. The Germans themselves now think they're going to win. So one of their chief strategists on the 25th of August,
who are basically very energetic and desperate to prove themselves. But also, Jophe sees something that most people have completely missed. Most people at this point assume the Germans are going to win. The Germans themselves now think they're going to win. So one of their chief strategists on the 25th of August,|||他们基本上都精力充沛，急于证明自己。而且，霞飞看到了大多数人完全忽视的一点。当时大多数人都认为德国人会赢。德国人自己现在也认为他们会赢。因此，在8月25日，他们的一位首席战略家，
a guy called Colonel Gerhard Tappen tells his colleagues, he says, in six weeks we shall finish the job. And that was the target, wasn't it, of the Schiffenpan, that it had to be done within six weeks? Yeah, we will finish the French off, and then we'll use the trains to get all our troops back to East Prussia, to Galicia, whatever, to deal with the Russians. But Joff, as he looks at these maps,
a guy called Colonel Gerhard Tappen tells his colleagues, he says, in six weeks we shall finish the job. And that was the target, wasn't it, of the Schiffenpan, that it had to be done within six weeks? Yeah, we will finish the French off, and then we'll use the trains to get all our troops back to East Prussia, to Galicia, whatever, to deal with the Russians. But Joff, as he looks at these maps,|||一个名叫格哈德·塔彭（Gerhard Tappen）的上校告诉他的同事们，他说，六周内我们将完成任务。这不就是施里芬计划的目标吗，必须在六周内完成？是的，我们将消灭法军，然后利用火车将所有部队运回东普鲁士、加利西亚或任何地方，去对付俄国人。但是霞飞在看着这些地图时，
he can see that the German offensive is now very, very stretched. So they have come an incredibly long way in a very short time. In three weeks, they've travelled 200 miles and they've thrust deep into France. But that's a problem for them. Half of their lorries have broken down. They're using thousands and thousands of horses to transport their supplies. Or they're carrying their supplies, physically carrying them themselves. Their horses are dropping dead with exhaustion.
he can see that the German offensive is now very, very stretched. So they have come an incredibly long way in a very short time. In three weeks, they've travelled 200 miles and they've thrust deep into France. But that's a problem for them. Half of their lorries have broken down. They're using thousands and thousands of horses to transport their supplies. Or they're carrying their supplies, physically carrying them themselves. Their horses are dropping dead with exhaustion.|||他能看出德军的攻势现在已经拉得非常、非常长了。他们在极短的时间内走了极其漫长的一段路。在三周内，他们行进了200英里，并深入法国腹地。但这对他们来说是个问题。他们有一半的卡车抛锚了。他们动用了成千上万匹马来运输补给。或者他们自己背着补给，亲手扛着。他们的马匹因为精疲力竭而纷纷倒毙。
They're men who are not rested and rotated at all. There's no system for doing that. are carrying massively heavy packs. They've all got, I'm very familiar with this issue, they've got new ill-fitting footwear that means they've got horrendous blisters. It's very hot. And so they have begun to, A, to slow down
They're men who are not rested and rotated at all. There's no system for doing that. are carrying massively heavy packs. They've all got, I'm very familiar with this issue, they've got new ill-fitting footwear that means they've got horrendous blisters. It's very hot. And so they have begun to, A, to slow down|||他们的士兵根本没有得到休息和轮换。根本没有这样的轮换制度。他们背着沉重无比的行囊。他们都有——我对这个问题非常熟悉——他们穿着不合脚的新鞋，这意味着他们的脚上磨出了可怕的水泡。天气非常炎热。因此，他们开始：A，放慢速度；
and B, to become very ragged and disorganized. So the further they go, the more mistakes they make. They get lost, they get jumbled up. They're basically making map reading errors. That's not very German, is it? No, this is the thing. They're behaving in a very un-German way. You could argue this was the fundamental weakness of the whole Schleafen plan that looks great on paper.
and B, to become very ragged and disorganized. So the further they go, the more mistakes they make. They get lost, they get jumbled up. They're basically making map reading errors. That's not very German, is it? No, this is the thing. They're behaving in a very un-German way. You could argue this was the fundamental weakness of the whole Schleafen plan that looks great on paper.|||B，变得衣衫褴褛、混乱不堪。所以他们走得越远，犯的错误就越多。他们迷路了，他们乱成一团。他们基本上犯了读图错误。这可不太像德国人的风格，对吧？不，问题就在这里。他们的行为非常不符合德国人的作风。你可以认为，这就是整个施里芬计划在纸面上看起来很美，但实际上却存在的根本弱点。
But in reality, your Loriz are going to break down. Your men are going to get blisters. And the Schleafen plan made no allowance for basically, you know, natural human failings. So, I mean, this is a key element of war, isn't it? Dominic, you mustn't overextend your supply lines. And you have spotted this, whereas Schleafen hadn't. You and I and Jophe are clearly cut from the similar. we're unflappable in that way
But in reality, your Loriz are going to break down. Your men are going to get blisters. And the Schleafen plan made no allowance for basically, you know, natural human failings. So, I mean, this is a key element of war, isn't it? Dominic, you mustn't overextend your supply lines. And you have spotted this, whereas Schleafen hadn't. You and I and Jophe are clearly cut from the similar. we're unflappable in that way|||但在现实中，你的卡车会抛锚。你的士兵会长水泡。而施里芬计划根本没有考虑到，你知道的，人类自然会有的缺陷。所以，我的意思是，这是战争的一个关键要素，对吧？多米尼克，你绝不能过度延伸你的补给线。而你发现了这一点，但施里芬却没有。你、我和霞飞显然是一类人。我们在那方面都沉着冷静
but we're not histrionic like a German general having our lunch right exactly a rest of history scheduling meeting I think is the technical term for a lunch right now the Germans are about to make a massive massive misjudgment
but we're not histrionic like a German general having our lunch right exactly a rest of history scheduling meeting I think is the technical term for a lunch right now the Germans are about to make a massive massive misjudgment|||但我们不像德国将军那样爱演戏，我们只是在吃午餐。没错，“历史的余烬排期会议”我想这是午餐的专业术语吧。现在，德国人即将做出一个巨大、巨大的误判。
so Malka's original plan was for them to go over the top of Paris and to encircle it to go all the way around it and encircle it from the west but in the last days of August the top German field commander who's a man called Karl von Bulolf he decides, let's change the plan. We probably don't even need to bother encircling Paris.
so Malka's original plan was for them to go over the top of Paris and to encircle it to go all the way around it and encircle it from the west but in the last days of August the top German field commander who's a man called Karl von Bulolf he decides, let's change the plan. We probably don't even need to bother encircling Paris.|||所以小毛奇（Moltke）最初的计划是让他们从巴黎上方越过并将其包围，绕过巴黎并从西侧对其进行包围。但在8月的最后几天，德国最高野战指挥官、一个名叫卡尔·冯·比洛（Karl von Bülow）的人决定：我们改变计划吧。我们甚至可能不必费心去包围巴黎了。
And he says to the topmost bit of the army, so the right wing of the German army, which is under Alexander von Kluk. He says, don't bother going around Paris. Turn inwards before you get to Paris, kind of turn down towards the flank of the retreating British and French. Can I ask a question?
And he says to the topmost bit of the army, so the right wing of the German army, which is under Alexander von Kluk. He says, don't bother going around Paris. Turn inwards before you get to Paris, kind of turn down towards the flank of the retreating British and French. Can I ask a question?|||他对军队的最前沿部分，也就是由亚历山大·冯·克鲁克（Alexander von Kluck）率领的德军右翼说。他说，别费心思绕过巴黎了。在到达巴黎之前向内转，差不多是朝着撤退中的英法联军的侧翼转向。我可以问个问题吗？
Is this because genuinely he thinks they don't need to bother enveloping Paris? Or is it because they're all so tired and knackard, that they think, oh, we're just cut a corner? I think it may be a tiny element of both. They are very tired by this point. They are exhausted and they are very worried about their supply lines. But as well, they think they assume the British and French, because they've been retreating
Is this because genuinely he thinks they don't need to bother enveloping Paris? Or is it because they're all so tired and knackard, that they think, oh, we're just cut a corner? I think it may be a tiny element of both. They are very tired by this point. They are exhausted and they are very worried about their supply lines. But as well, they think they assume the British and French, because they've been retreating|||这是因为他真心认为他们不需要费心包围巴黎？还是因为他们都太累、太筋疲力尽了，以至于觉得，哦，我们干脆抄个近路吧？我认为这两者都有那么一点点因素。他们到这个时候已经非常疲惫了。他们筋疲力尽，而且非常担心他们的补给线。但同时，他们认为——他们假设英法联军因为一直在撤退，
so far, are beaten, and they can just turn, sort of envelop them, squeeze them against their borders. And we were talking about enormous armours and enormous distances and crush them between them. The battle can I? Yeah. Instead of doing the whole plan, they will basically. use Eastern France as their battlefield and they will envelop the Allied armies
so far, are beaten, and they can just turn, sort of envelop them, squeeze them against their borders. And we were talking about enormous armours and enormous distances and crush them between them. The battle can I? Yeah. Instead of doing the whole plan, they will basically. use Eastern France as their battlefield and they will envelop the Allied armies|||已经被打败了，他们可以顺势掉头，将其包围，把他们挤压到国境线上。我们刚刚还在谈论庞大的装甲力量和巨大的距离，并在他们之间将其粉碎。坎尼会战？是的。他们不再执行整个计划，而是基本上将法国东部作为他们的战场，他们将包围盟军军队，
and crush them. So they crush the armies, they crush the armies and then Paris surrenders. That's the plan. And then the French will have no one left and they'll have to surrender. They won't even need to take Paris. I have to say I am massively, massively simplifying this because to emphasize, we are not the rest is military history. But the key point is that the German
and crush them. So they crush the armies, they crush the armies and then Paris surrenders. That's the plan. And then the French will have no one left and they'll have to surrender. They won't even need to take Paris. I have to say I am massively, massively simplifying this because to emphasize, we are not the rest is military history. But the key point is that the German|||并将其粉碎。所以他们粉碎军队，粉碎军队，然后巴黎投降。这就是计划。然后法国人就会无人可用，不得不投降。他们甚至不需要攻占巴黎。我必须说，我极大地、极大地简化了这一点，因为要强调的是，我们不是“军事史的余烬”。但关键点在于，德国
commanders have abandoned their original blueprint. They think the British and French armies are so broken they just need to pursue and annihilate them. So now they are not following a sort of plan, they are basically making it up as they go along. And the key thing about this is that they are massively underestimating the Allies. And the reason for that, presumably, is the sheer number of people that you were talking about, kind of, we're talking
commanders have abandoned their original blueprint. They think the British and French armies are so broken they just need to pursue and annihilate them. So now they are not following a sort of plan, they are basically making it up as they go along. And the key thing about this is that they are massively underestimating the Allies. And the reason for that, presumably, is the sheer number of people that you were talking about, kind of, we're talking|||指挥官们已经放弃了他们最初的蓝图。他们认为英法军队已经溃不成军，他们只需要追击并歼灭他们。所以现在他们没有遵循什么计划，他们基本上是走一步算一步。而这其中的关键在于，他们严重低估了盟军。究其原因，大概就是你刚才谈到的庞大的人数，某种程度上，我们谈论的是
about hundreds of thousands, millions of people. So even if you wipe out, you inflict what seems countless numbers of casualties, you aren't necessarily breaking the capacity of an industrial nation to continue the fight? I mean, is that essentially the misjudgment? I think exactly. I think especially a country like France, which is very highly militarized, which is basically now gone to honor to a total war footing, is mobilizing all its manpower. There are a lot of Frenchmen left, and France is a very serious country. And, you know, you can win these enormous battles in the Battle of the Frontiers, but there's still a long way to go. And I think the Germans don't realize that, actually. Because I guess the only war for previously in history that
about hundreds of thousands, millions of people. So even if you wipe out, you inflict what seems countless numbers of casualties, you aren't necessarily breaking the capacity of an industrial nation to continue the fight? I mean, is that essentially the misjudgment? I think exactly. I think especially a country like France, which is very highly militarized, which is basically now gone to honor to a total war footing, is mobilizing all its manpower. There are a lot of Frenchmen left, and France is a very serious country. And, you know, you can win these enormous battles in the Battle of the Frontiers, but there's still a long way to go. And I think the Germans don't realize that, actually. Because I guess the only war for previously in history that|||几十万、数百万的人口。所以，即使你消灭了，造成了看似无数的伤亡，你也不一定会打破一个工业化国家继续战斗的能力？我的意思是，这本质上就是他们的误判吗？我认为正是如此。我认为尤其是像法国这样高度军 militarized（军事化）的国家，现在基本上已经进入了总体战状态，正在动员其所有的劳动力。还剩下很多法国人，法国是一个非常严肃的国家。而且，你知道的，你可以在边界战役中赢得这些巨大的战役，但前方还有很长的路要走。我想德国人实际上并没有意识到这一点。因为我猜，历史上以前唯一的一场战争，
would have taught that lesson, would have been the American Civil War. Yes, I guess so. Because the Franco-Prussian War is done and dusted pretty quickly. Yeah. You know, they encircle and capture the, they capture the emperor, Napoleon III, and then it's pretty much done. Whereas with this, you know, the canvas is so much bigger and the numbers are so much bigger. I guess the American soldiers. But also the industrial capacity is so great and the supplies and everything.
would have taught that lesson, would have been the American Civil War. Yes, I guess so. Because the Franco-Prussian War is done and dusted pretty quickly. Yeah. You know, they encircle and capture the, they capture the emperor, Napoleon III, and then it's pretty much done. Whereas with this, you know, the canvas is so much bigger and the numbers are so much bigger. I guess the American soldiers. But also the industrial capacity is so great and the supplies and everything.|||能教会这个教训的，大概就是美国内战了。是的，我猜是的。因为普法战争很快就结束了。是的。你知道，他们包围并俘虏了……他们俘虏了皇帝拿破仑三世，然后差不多就结束了。而与此相比，你知道，这幅画卷要宏大得多，数字也庞大得多。我猜美国士兵。但同时工业能力也如此巨大，物资和一切都……
Yeah, railways, all of that stuff. The factories. Yeah, exactly. And this is something that nobody really understands, I guess, at this point. And it's also a testament, actually, to the French and the British have retreated 200 miles, but they have actually kept their discipline. They haven't fallen apart in a complete, chaotic sort of shambles. They are very well-trained armies by and large, and very cohesive.
Yeah, railways, all of that stuff. The factories. Yeah, exactly. And this is something that nobody really understands, I guess, at this point. And it's also a testament, actually, to the French and the British have retreated 200 miles, but they have actually kept their discipline. They haven't fallen apart in a complete, chaotic sort of shambles. They are very well-trained armies by and large, and very cohesive.|||是的，铁路，所有这些东西。工厂。是的，完全如此。我想，这一点在当时是没人真正理解的。这实际上也证明了，法国人和英国人虽然撤退了200英里，但他们实际上保持了纪律。他们并没有陷入彻底混乱的烂摊子中。大体上，他们是非常精锐的军队，且极具凝聚力。
So they've actually managed to pull it off, as we will see. Now, then there's a big stroke of luck. On the 1st of September, one of the staff officers, the French 5th Army, is handed a, gift from the front and it is a blood-drenched backpack taken from the body of a German cavalry officer and he opens it and inside is some food and some papers and clothes but above all there is a map and the map is marked and the map shows the deployment of every corps in Alexander von Klux's first army with pencil markings even showing where they're going to be sleeping and it shows without doubt that this bloc is turning away from the French capital he's going inwards and
So they've actually managed to pull it off, as we will see. Now, then there's a big stroke of luck. On the 1st of September, one of the staff officers, the French 5th Army, is handed a, gift from the front and it is a blood-drenched backpack taken from the body of a German cavalry officer and he opens it and inside is some food and some papers and clothes but above all there is a map and the map is marked and the map shows the deployment of every corps in Alexander von Klux's first army with pencil markings even showing where they're going to be sleeping and it shows without doubt that this bloc is turning away from the French capital he's going inwards and|||所以正如我们将看到的，他们实际上成功地做到了这一点。现在，紧接着发生了一个天大的好运气。9月1日，法军第5集团军的一名参谋军官收到了一份来自前线的“礼物”——那是一个从一名德国骑兵军官尸体上取下的血迹斑斑的背包。他打开背包，里面有一些食物、一些文件和衣服，但最重要的是，里面有一张地图。地图上做好了标记，显示了亚历山大·冯·克鲁克第一集团军中每一个军的部署情况，甚至还有铅笔标记，标明了他们将要在哪里过夜。这张地图毫无疑问地表明，这个集群正在背离法国首都，他正在向内转，
he's actually, without realising it, he's exposing himself to an allied counterattack. And isn't there also, the French are getting information from the Eiffel Tower, which kind of serves as an eavesdropping device? Oh, that's a good fact. I didn't know that. To intercept German signals, I gather. So the Eiffel Tower is an important military installation. Yeah, it's not completely useless. No.
he's actually, without realising it, he's exposing himself to an allied counterattack. And isn't there also, the French are getting information from the Eiffel Tower, which kind of serves as an eavesdropping device? Oh, that's a good fact. I didn't know that. To intercept German signals, I gather. So the Eiffel Tower is an important military installation. Yeah, it's not completely useless. No.|||而且他实际上在毫无察觉的情况下，将自己暴露在盟军的反击之下。话说回来，法国人是不是还从埃菲尔铁塔那里获取信息？埃菲尔铁塔在某种程度上充当了窃听装置。哦，这个事实很有趣。我以前不知道。我猜是为了截获德国人的信号。所以埃菲尔铁塔是一个重要的军事设施。是的，它并非完全无用。不。
So let's move forward three days to Friday the 4th of September. The Allies have fallen back to the Valley of the Marn. So you have a million French and British soldiers. soldiers stretched across this front. And to get this into people's minds, the front is 150 miles long. It goes from the suburbs of Paris all the way east to the great eastern fortress of Verdun. And advancing towards them are a million Germans, just under a million really. They're very confident the Germans. They think they're going to win, but they are sore and hungry and ragged and very tired. We did the Battle of Mons in the last episode. We quoted
So let's move forward three days to Friday the 4th of September. The Allies have fallen back to the Valley of the Marn. So you have a million French and British soldiers. soldiers stretched across this front. And to get this into people's minds, the front is 150 miles long. It goes from the suburbs of Paris all the way east to the great eastern fortress of Verdun. And advancing towards them are a million Germans, just under a million really. They're very confident the Germans. They think they're going to win, but they are sore and hungry and ragged and very tired. We did the Battle of Mons in the last episode. We quoted|||让我们把时间快进三天，来到9月4日星期五。盟军已经撤退到了马恩河谷。所以你有一百万法军和英军士兵。士兵们沿着这条战线排开。为了让人们有个概念，这条战线长达150英里。它从巴黎郊区一直向东延伸到伟大的东部要塞凡尔登。向他们推进的是一百万德国人，实际上略少于一百万。德国人非常自信。他们认为自己会赢，但他们又酸痛、又饥饿、衣衫褴褛而且非常疲惫。我们在上一集里讲过蒙斯战役。我们引用了
a bloke called Walter Blum. And he describes his own troops. He says, we looked unshaved, unwashed, like prehistoric savages, covered with dust and spattered with blood, blackened with powder smoke, and torn threadbare by thorns and barbed wire. So although there is this image of the Germans as sort of invincible and indomitable and whatnot, they are at the absolute limit of their endurance. They're wearing this, we'll see this again and again in this story, actually.
a bloke called Walter Blum. And he describes his own troops. He says, we looked unshaved, unwashed, like prehistoric savages, covered with dust and spattered with blood, blackened with powder smoke, and torn threadbare by thorns and barbed wire. So although there is this image of the Germans as sort of invincible and indomitable and whatnot, they are at the absolute limit of their endurance. They're wearing this, we'll see this again and again in this story, actually.|||一个叫沃尔特·布鲁姆（Walter Blum）的人的话。他这样描述自己的军队。他说：“我们看起来没刮胡子、没洗脸，就像史前野兽一样，浑身沾满尘土和血迹，被火药烟雾熏黑，衣服也被荆棘和铁丝网刮得破烂不堪。”因此，尽管人们对德国人有一种战无不胜、不可战胜之类的印象，但他们其实已经到了忍耐的绝对极限。他们穿着这身衣服——我们在接下来的故事中会一次又一次地看到这一点，实际上。
They're wearing the same clothes by and large that they set out in. and they haven't washed for weeks, so they really are, you know, in a terrible state. So a pungent, pungent smell, descending on Paris. It's exactly. So that very day, actually, the 4th of September, General von Kluck sent a signal to German Supreme Command, and he said, we're at the limit. My men cannot really go on. They are exhausted, and we need reinforcements. And at his headquarters, you know, as he's polishing off his long lunch, General Joff,
They're wearing the same clothes by and large that they set out in. and they haven't washed for weeks, so they really are, you know, in a terrible state. So a pungent, pungent smell, descending on Paris. It's exactly. So that's what's happening. So that very day, actually, the 4th of September, General von Kluck sent a signal to German Supreme Command, and he said, we're at the limit. My men cannot really go on. They are exhausted, and we need reinforcements. And at his headquarters, you know, as he's polishing off his long lunch, General Joff,|||他们大体上还穿着出发时穿的那身衣服。他们已经好几个星期没洗过澡了，所以他们真的，你知道的，处于一种糟糕透顶的状态。因此，一股刺鼻的、刺鼻的气味笼罩着巴黎。正是如此。情况就是这样。事实上，就在那天，即9月4日，克鲁克将军向德国最高指挥部发去了电报，他说：“我们已经到了极限。我的部下真的无法继续前行了。他们已经筋疲力尽，我们需要增援。”而在他的司令部里，你知道的，当霞飞将军正在享用他那漫长的午餐时，
thinks to himself, this is the moment. And that evening, the 4th of September, he issues General Order number six. And he says, now that the German First Army has turned inwards to finish us off, we'll concentrate all our forces against this army, will strike when they're least expecting it. We will thrust a wedge between the German first and second armies,
thinks to himself, this is the moment. And that evening, the 4th of September, he issues General Order number six. And he says, now that the German First Army has turned inwards to finish us off, we'll concentrate all our forces against this army, will strike when they're least expecting it. We will thrust a wedge between the German first and second armies,|||心想：就是现在。9月4日那天晚上，他发布了第六号总命令。他说：“既然德国第一集团军已经向内转试图彻底消灭我们，我们就将集中所有兵力对付这支军队，在他们最意想不到的时候发起进攻。我们将在德国第一和第二集团军之间打入一个楔子，”
so that's on their sort of western flank, and we will drive them from our sacred soil. Great stuff. But he actually, for this to work, The wedge that he wants to drive between the two German armies is going to be the British Expeditionary Force. Our own dear countrymen. Is that because they're positioned where they happen to have ended up?
so that's on their sort of western flank, and we will drive them from our sacred soil. Great stuff. But he actually, for this to work, The wedge that he wants to drive between the two German armies is going to be the British Expeditionary Force. Our own dear countrymen. Is that because they're positioned where they happen to have ended up?|||也就是在他们的西侧翼，我们将把他们从我们神圣的土地上赶出去。太棒了。但他实际上，为了让这个计划成功，他想要插入德军两个集团军之间的楔子，将是英国远征军。我们亲爱的同胞。这是因为他们恰好驻扎在那个位置吗？
I mean, it's not a kind of our fighting spirit. No, no, no. He's not saying the only people who can do this are the British. He's actually looking at his map and saying, well, the British are the people in the right place, so they're going to have to do it. I just wanted if perhaps there was a kind of political dimension to it as well. I don't know.
I mean, it's not a kind of our fighting spirit. No, no, no. He's not saying the only people who can do this are the British. He's actually looking at his map and saying, well, the British are the people in the right place, so they're going to have to do it. I just wanted if perhaps there was a kind of political dimension to it as well. I don't know.|||我的意思是，这并不是出于我们的战斗精神。不，不，不。他并不是说只有英国人才能做到这一点。他实际上是在看着地图说，好吧，英国人处于正确的位置，所以他们必须这么做。我只是想知道其中是否也包含某种政治考量。我不知道。
I don't think so. I think it's just that they're in the right place to do the right job. Maybe, I mean, I know this, the trouble doing the First World War is there a load of people there who literally know like the details of everybody's backpack and stuff. So they're almost certainly going to be flooding the rest of the history. Well, they'll be enjoying a forensic account. Yeah, it's like that bloke who wrote like a 40,000 word essay about the bows that people used Ashinkul or something. Remember that when you did that? I do.
I don't think so. I think it's just that they're in the right place to do the right job. Maybe, I mean, I know this, the trouble doing the First World War is there a load of people there who literally know like the details of everybody's backpack and stuff. So they're almost certainly going to be flooding the rest of the history. Well, they'll be enjoying a forensic account. Yeah, it's like that bloke who wrote like a 40,000 word essay about the bows that people used Ashinkul or something. Remember that when you did that? I do.|||我不这么认为。我认为这只是因为他们处在做正确事情的正确位置上。也许吧，我的意思是，我知道这一点，研究第一次世界大战的麻烦在于，那里有一大群人，他们对每个人的背包等细节了如指掌。所以他们几乎肯定会涌入《历史的余烬》。好吧，他们会享受一份细致入微的账单。是的，就像那个写了一篇四万字论文来讨论人们在阿金库尔战役中使用的弓之类东西的家伙。你还记得你当时做那个的时候吗？我记得。
Yes, I do. Anyway, I don't want to open old wounds, Tom. So the 5th of September, we began with this. This is the scene we began with this, is the crucial moments. And I have to say, is an absolutely unbelievably melodramatic scene. Jofu, as we said before, it loves a drive. He puts on his massive cape, and he drives 100 miles to the chateau. He doesn't drive, Dominique.
Yes, I do. Anyway, I don't want to open old wounds, Tom. So the 5th of September, we began with this. This is the scene we began with this, is the crucial moments. And I have to say, is an absolutely unbelievably melodramatic scene. Jofu, as we said before, it loves a drive. He puts on his massive cape, and he drives 100 miles to the chateau. He doesn't drive, Dominique.|||是的，我记得。总之，我不想揭伤疤，汤姆。所以9月5日，我们就是从这里开始的。这就是我们开篇的场景，这是关键时刻。我必须说，这是一个绝对令人难以置信的充满戏剧性的场景。霞飞，正如我们之前所说，他喜欢坐车兜风。他穿上巨大的披风，坐车行驶了100英里来到城堡。他可没自己开车，多米尼克。
No, of course, he doesn't drive. Formula 1 winning. Yes, that's right. He is driven, I should say, to the chateau. of Vu Le Penil. So that's where Sir John French is staying. And he begins by telling Sir John, he says, on your decision now rests the fate of Europe. And then he sets out his plan, as you described, the sweep of the battlefield, all these intricate bits of machinery, the Germans blundering on towards the precipice, all this. And then he turns to Sir John French,
No, of course, he doesn't drive. Formula 1 winning. Yes, that's right. He is driven, I should say, to the chateau. of Vu Le Penil. So that's what Sir John French is staying. And he begins by telling Sir John, he says, on your decision now rests the fate of Europe. And then he sets out his plan, as you described, the sweep of the battlefield, all these intricate bits of machinery, the Germans blundering on towards the precipice, all this. And then he turns to Sir John French,|||不，他当然没开车。F1冠军。是的，没错。应该说，他是被车送到城堡的。也就是乌·勒佩尼尔（Vu Le Penil）城堡。这就是约翰·弗伦奇爵士下榻的地方。他首先对约翰说，欧洲的命运现在取决于你的决定。然后他阐述了他的计划，正如你所描述的那样，战场的扫荡，所有这些复杂的机械部件，德国人跌跌撞撞地走向悬崖，等等。然后他转向约翰·弗伦奇爵士，
and his voice is throbbing with passion. He barely ever speaks. So this is a really remarkable moment. And he says, the lives of all French people, the soil of France, the future of Europe depends on you joining this battle. I cannot believe the British Army will refuse to do its share in this supreme crisis. And he looks at Sir John in the eyes and he says, Monsieur Le Marchechele, it's the France who is suppli. Feel Marshal or whatever. It's France who is begging you. The honour of England is at stake. And he's been thumping the table. is doing that. And then there's this long silence. And everybody looks at Sir John French with great red face, bright redder than ever. And there are tears trickling down his cheeks.
and his voice is throbbing with passion. He barely ever speaks. So this is a really remarkable moment. And he says, the lives of all French people, the soil of France, the future of Europe depends on you joining this battle. I cannot believe the British Army will refuse to do its share in this supreme crisis. And he looks at Sir John in the eyes and he says, Monsieur Le Marchechele, it's the France who is suppli. Feel Marshal or whatever. It's France who is begging you. The honour of England is at stake. And he's been thumping the table. is doing that. And then there's this long silence. And everybody looks at Sir John French with great red face, bright redder than ever. And there are tears trickling down his cheeks.|||他的声音饱含激情。他平时几乎从不说话。所以这是一个非常了不起的时刻。他说：“所有法国人的生命，法国的土地，欧洲的未来，都取决于你是否加入这场战役。我无法相信英国军队会在这个至关重要的危机中拒绝尽自己的一份力。”他直视着约翰的眼睛说：“元帅阁下，是法国在恳求您。陆军元帅还是别的什么。是法国在求您。英格兰的荣誉危在旦夕。”他一直在捶桌子。他就是这么做的。然后是一阵漫长的沉默。每个人都看着约翰·弗伦奇，他的脸红得发紫，比以往任何时候都要红。有泪水顺着他的脸颊流了下来。
And he tries to say something in French. But he can't, he stumbles on his words. And eventually he just turns to one of his officers and he says, damn it, I can't explain. Tell him that all that men can do, our fellows will do. And the officer says in French to Jouf, the field marshal says, yes so we so joff drives back to his headquarters whereas junior officers are waiting now he knows that some of them are very skeptical about this they worry that their men have been retreating for so long they're too tired or they're too demoralized but joff gathers them and he says it's now or never it's victory or death gentlemen we shall fight on the man and that night he gives the final order to his million men troops who can no longer advance must keep the ground that
And he tries to say something in French. But he can't, he stumbles on his words. And eventually he just turns to one of his officers and he says, damn it, I can't explain. Tell him that all that men can do, our fellows will do. And the officer says in French to Jouf, the field marshal says, yes so we so joff drives back to his headquarters whereas junior officers are waiting now he knows that some of them are very skeptical about this they worry that their men have been retreating for so long they're too tired or they're too demoralized but joff gathers them and he says it's now or never it's victory or death gentlemen we shall fight on the man and that night he gives the final order to his million men troops who can no longer advance must keep the ground that|||他试图用法语说点什么。但他做不到，他说话结结巴巴的。最后他只是转向自己的一名军官说：“该死，我解释不清楚。告诉他，凡是人能做到的，我们的人都会做到。”那名军官用法语对霞飞说：“元帅说，是的，所以我们……”于是霞飞开车回到了他的司令部，而低级军官们正在那里等待。现在他知道其中一些人对此非常怀疑，他们担心他们的部下撤退了这么久，实在是太累了或者士气太低落了。但霞飞把他们召集起来说：“现在或永不，这是胜利还是死亡，先生们，我们将在马恩河战斗到底。”那天晚上，他向他的一百万大军下达了最后一道命令：无法继续前进的军队必须不惜一切代价守住已经赢得的阵地。
has been worn at any cost. They must die where they stand rather than give way. Now, that same day in Paris, his old boss, General Galliani, dying, has been talking to his subordinates. And one of these guys says to Galliani, well, what happens if it goes battling? What happens if we're overwhelmed? Where should be the point that we retreat to? Galiini says to him, nowhere.
has been worn at any cost. They must die where they stand rather than give way. Now, that same day in Paris, his old boss, General Galliani, dying, has been talking to his subordinates. And one of these guys says to Galliani, well, what happens if it goes battling? What happens if we're overwhelmed? Where should be the point that we retreat to? Galiini says to him, nowhere.|||他们必须死在阵地上，也绝不退让。就在同一天在巴黎，他老上司、垂死的加利埃尼将军正在与他的下属交谈。其中一个人对加利埃尼说：“好吧，如果战斗不顺利会怎么样？如果我们被压垮了怎么办？我们应该撤退到什么地方？”加利埃尼对他说：“哪儿也不去。”
We fight to the death. Great stuff. So, Dominic, this is, I mean, this is three. thrilling, isn't it? Because at dawn on the 6th of September, the artillery barrage begins, thousands and thousands of guns. And I guess this is, I mean, a noise like it has never been heard before. It's the greatest man-made storm in history. And then for fans of French military bugles, the exciting moment comes when they sound, tens of thousands of Frenchmen begin to pour forward. The French Elin, combined with French industrial might and the battle of the Marne begins and the excitement is so intense that I can't really cope with it.
We fight to the death. Great stuff. So, Dominic, this is, I mean, this is three. thrilling, isn't it? Because at dawn on the 6th of September, the artillery barrage begins, thousands and thousands of guns. And I guess this is, I mean, a noise like it has never been heard before. It's the greatest man-made storm in history. And then for fans of French military bugles, the exciting moment comes when they sound, tens of thousands of Frenchmen begin to pour forward. The French Elin, combined with French industrial might and the battle of the Marne begins and the excitement is so intense that I can't really cope with it.|||我们血战到底。太棒了。所以，多米尼克，这真是……太惊心动魄了，对吧？因为在9月6日黎明时分，炮火轰鸣开始，成千上万门大炮齐鸣。我想这是……我的意思是，这是前所未有的噪音。这是人类历史上最伟大的狂风暴雨。然后，对于法国军号的粉丝来说，激动人心的时刻来临了，当号角吹响时，数万名法国人开始向前涌去。法国的精英，结合法国的工业力量，马恩河战役开始了，这种激动人心的气氛如此强烈，以至于我简直无法承受。
I doubt you can cope. I can see seeing you on the video. You can't possibly cope with it. So we are going to take a break, have a breather, and we will be back in a few minutes. This episode is brought to you by Surf Shark. Now, had Mary Queen of Scots
I doubt you can cope. I can see seeing you on the video. You can't possibly cope with it. So we are going to take a break, have a breather, and we will be back in a few minutes. This episode is brought to you by Surf Shark. Now, had Mary Queen of Scots|||我猜你也无法承受。我看你在视频里的样子。你根本承受不了。所以我们要休息一下，喘口气，几分钟后我们会回来。本期节目由 Surf Shark 赞助播出。话说回来，苏格兰女王玛丽
been just a little bit more careful with her correspondence, then she might well have avoided becoming a cautionary tale of treason. So she slipped her ciphered letters into beer barrels. Methods today have changed, but the risk of interception, of course, always remains. Your information is more vulnerable than ever, and perhaps especially when it's online. Trackers and advertisers and apps collecting your data all the time. And if you're using public Wi-Fi, then your activity can be monitored by anyone who is sharing the network.
been just a little bit more careful with her correspondence, then she might well have avoided becoming a cautionary tale of treason. So she slipped her ciphered letters into beer barrels. Methods today have changed, but the risk of interception, of course, always remains. Your information is more vulnerable than ever, and perhaps especially when it's online. Trackers and advertisers and apps collecting your data all the time. And if you're using public Wi-Fi, then your activity can be monitored by anyone who is sharing the network.|||如果对她的信件稍微小心一点的话，她本可以避免成为叛国罪的反面教材。因此，她把加密的信件塞进了啤酒桶里。如今的方法变了，但被拦截的风险当然一直存在。你的信息比以往任何时候都更加脆弱，尤其是当你在网上时。追踪器、广告商和应用程序一直在收集你的数据。如果你在使用公共 Wi-Fi，那么任何与你共享网络的人都可以监视你的活动。
work that you are on. And this is where Surfshark comes in. It's a VPN that encrypts your internet connection, thereby keeps your personal data secure. So you can also change your digital location, giving you access to your favourite sites and streaming services wherever you are. So protect your data, browse securely from anywhere, no cipher, no career, certainly no beer barrel required. Go to surfshark.com slash TRIH or you can use the code TRIH at the checkout to get four extra months of Surfshark VPN
work that you are on. And this is where Surfshark comes in. It's a VPN that encrypts your internet connection, thereby keeps your personal data secure. So you can also change your digital location, giving you access to your favourite sites and streaming services wherever you are. So protect your data, browse securely from anywhere, no cipher, no career, certainly no beer barrel required. Go to surfshark.com slash TRIH or you can use the code TRIH at the checkout to get four extra months of Surfshark VPN|||这就是 Surfshark 发挥作用的地方。它是一款虚拟专用网络（VPN），可以加密你的互联网连接，从而保证你的个人数据安全。因此，你还可以更改你的数字位置，无论你在哪里都可以访问你最喜欢的网站和流媒体服务. 所以，保护你的数据，从任何地方安全浏览，无需密码，无需信使，当然也无需啤酒桶。访问 surfshark.com 斜杠 TRIH，或者你可以在结账时使用代码 TRIH 以获得四个月的 Surfshark VPN 额外时长
plus a 30-day money-back guarantee. TD Bank knows that running a small business is a journey from startup to growing and managing your business. That's why they have a dedicated small business advice hub on their website to provide tips and insights on business banking to entrepreneurs. No matter the stage of business you're in, visit td.com
plus a 30-day money-back guarantee. TD Bank knows that running a small business is a journey from startup to growing and managing your business. That's why they have a dedicated small business advice hub on their website to provide tips and insights on business banking to entrepreneurs. No matter the stage of business you're in, visit td.com|||以及 30 天退款保证。道明银行（TD Bank）深知经营一家小企业是一段从创业到发展再到管理企业的旅程。这就是为什么他们在官网上专门设立了一个小企业咨询中心，为创业者提供关于企业银行服务的建议和见解。无论你处于企业发展的哪个阶段，请访问 td.com
slash small business advice to find out more or to match with a TD small business banking account manager. Hi everybody. It is Dominic here. Now, I have been working on something incredibly exciting, a special treat for the members of the Rest is History Club. Every Friday for the next few weeks, I will be joined by our regular Restis History producer, Tabby Siret, and we will be discussing a different great book from history, from J.R. Tolkien's fantasy classic, The Hobbit,
slash small business advice to find out more or to match with a TD small business banking account manager. Hi everybody. It is Dominic here. Now, I have been working on something incredibly exciting, a special treat for the members of the Rest is History Club. Every Friday for the next few weeks, I will be joined by our regular Restis History producer, Tabby Siret, and we will be discussing a different great book from history, from J.R. Tolkien's fantasy classic, The Hobbit,|||斜杠 small business advice 以了解更多信息，或与道明银行的小企业银行业务客户经理取得联系。大家好。我是多米尼克。现在，我一直在筹备一件令人无比兴奋的事情，这是为“历史的余烬”俱乐部会员准备的特别惊喜。在接下来的几周里，每周五我都会和我们常驻的“历史的余烬”制作人塔比·西雷特（Tabby Siret）一起，讨论历史上一本不同的伟大著作，从 J.R. 托尔金的奇幻经典《霍比特人》，
to Bram Stoker's horror novel, Dracula, to Margaret Atwood's dystopian fable, The Handmaid's Tale. And we will be exploring the lives of authors from Albert Camus to Truman Capote, and we'll be looking at the history behind their great books, the worlds they inhabited, the social and cultural contexts, and the secrets that their books hold. So if you want to hear Tabby and me delving into these great books, then all you have to do is to go to the rest is history.com to join the rest is history club. And you will get our thrilling books episodes every Friday.
布拉姆·斯托克（Bram Stoker）的恐怖小说《德古拉》，再到玛格丽特·阿特伍德（Margaret Atwood）的反乌托邦寓言《使女的故事》。我们还将探讨从阿尔贝·加缪（Albert Camus）到杜鲁门·卡波特（Truman Capote）等作家的生平，并研究他们伟大著作背后的历史、他们所生活的世界、社会与文化背景，以及这些书中所蕴含的秘密。因此，如果您想听塔比和我深入探讨这些伟大的著作，您只需访问therestishistory.com并加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部。您将在每周五获得我们精彩的书籍单集。
You'll get the regular bonus episodes of the Restis History Club that everybody loves so much. You'll get all the other amazing benefits. You'll get early access to episodes. You'll get ad-free listening, unbelievable benefits. So that is The Rest is History.com. This thrilling new content will be starting on Friday, the 5th of September. Bye-bye. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History.
您将获得大家喜爱的“历史其余部分”俱乐部的常规独家番外。您还将获得所有其他惊人的福利。您将获得单集的抢先收听权限。您将获得无广告收听的难以置信的福利。网址就是The Restis History.com。这项激动人心的新内容将于9月5日星期五开始。再见。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。
Dominic, the Battle of the Man has begun. Just how exciting is it? Tom, it's unbelievably exciting. So where are we? We're in Paris. We're on the night of the 7th of September, 1914. So the Battle of the Marn has now been raging for two days. But at his headquarters, General Galliani, he's got a dilemma.
多米尼克，马恩河战役已经打响了。这到底有多令人兴奋？汤姆，这简直令人兴奋得难以置信。那么我们在哪里？我们在巴黎。时间是1914年9月7日的夜晚。马恩河战役此时已经激战了两天。但在他的指挥部里，加利埃尼将军面临着一个两难的境地。
On the front, you know, it's all kicked off. And Joff needs every man that he can get. And they have commandeered every train and every truck in the city to get men to the front. However, the railway network is so. So clogged, the trains are wounded, with supply trains, with refugees and whatnot, that basically the whole system is close to breaking down. The Army's 7th Division have been on trains for 24 hours. They are now stuck in a place called Pontin, which is a suburb of northern Paris.
在前线，你知道的，战斗已经全面爆发了。霞飞需要他能调集的每一个人。他们已经征用了城里的每一列火车和每一辆卡车，把士兵运送到前线。然而，铁路网实在是太拥挤了，火车上挤满了物资列车、难民等等，以至于整个系统基本濒临崩溃。军队第七师已经在火车上待了24个小时。他们现在被困在一个叫蓬坦（Pontin）的地方，那是巴黎北部的一个郊区。
Now, Gelliani wants to get these men to the front. You know, the front, Tom, you may be wondering how far the front is. I'm wondering that. It's miles away. It's some miles, I put it that way. Some distance. So they can't walk anyway. How are they going to get there?
现在，加利埃尼想把这些人送到前线。你知道的，前线，汤姆，你可能在想前线有多远。我也在想这个。离得很远。离得很远，我这么说吧。有一段距离。所以他们无论如何是走不到的。他们要怎么去那里？
There's talk of using army lorries, but there's basically none left. And then somebody at Galeen in his headquarters, maybe Galeini himself says, you know, I know this sounds mad. Let's feel. But could they not take taxes to the front? Now, Paris normally has 10,000 taxes. And only 3,000 of them are operating, basically because so many drivers have gone to join the army. but 3,000 taxes is not nothing. And so Galliani says, great, let's do it.
有人谈到使用军用卡车，但基本上已经没有剩多少了。然后，加利埃尼指挥部里的某个人，也许是加利埃尼本人说，你知道，我知道这听起来很疯狂。让我们看看。难道他们不能坐出租车去前线吗？现在，巴黎通常有10000辆出租车。其中只有3000辆在运营，主要是因为太多的司机去参军了。但3000辆出租车也不是个小数目。所以加利埃尼说，太好了，就这样办。
So one of his officers rings the central police station and says, I want all taxes, every single tax in the city, sent to the Esplanade des Anvalide. So there's big, you know, the avalide, the big military complex when Napoleon is buried. In every street in Paris, the police go out and they flagged down these taxes. They basically kick the passengers out, and they say to the drivers, go to the military college at Les Invalide.
于是，他的一名军官给中央警察局打电话说，我要所有的出租车，城里的每一辆出租车，都派到荣军院广场（Esplanade des Invalides）。所以那里有很大的，你知道的，荣军院，拿破仑安葬的那个大型军事综合体。在巴黎的每一条街上，警察走出去，拦下这些出租车。他们基本上把乘客赶下车，然后对司机说，去荣军院的军事学院。
Now, most of these taxes are, Renault taxis. So I have to say, I'm not a massive fan of a Renault car, but there you go. They've got room for about five people each, and they can go no faster than 25 miles an hour. But by the standards of the day, that's not bad. It's quicker than walking, isn't it? It's a lot quicker than walking. Considering how many miles they've got to go.
现在，这些出租车大多是雷诺出租车。所以我必须说，我不是雷诺汽车的超级粉丝，但事实就是如此。它们每辆车大约能坐五个人，时速不超过25英里。但按当时的标准来看，这还算不错。总比步行快，不是吗？比步行快得多。考虑到他们要走多少英里。
Well, exactly. And we don't want to really, you know, we don't want to pin down exactly how many miles because we don't want to give everything away. But it's quite a distance. I think that's a detail for our subscribers, no? But it is a distance. So about 10 o'clock, the first convoy of taxis heads out, about 250 cars. They're led by this officer called Lieutenant Levasse, and only he knows where they're going, because it's a secret. And he says to the drivers, right, you stay in single file, you turn your headlights off, you can use your sort of reel, your kind of tail lights, but not your headlights.
嗯，确实如此。我们真的不想，你知道的，我们不想确切地确定有多少英里，因为我们不想把所有事情都剧透了。但距离确实相当远。我认为这是留给我们订阅者的细节，不是吗？但它确实有一段距离。因此，大约在10点钟，第一支出租车车队出发了，大约有250辆车。它们由一位名叫勒瓦瑟（Levasseur）中尉的军官带领，只有他知道他们要去哪里，因为这是一个秘密。他对司机们说，好了，你们排成单纵队，关掉大灯，你们可以使用某种尾灯，但不能用大灯。
The drivers, I have to say, are very, very unhappy about this. They're unhappy about losing their fares. They're also unhappy about driving with their lights off because they say, well, we're just going to drive into each other, which indeed a lot of them do. Anyway, after an awful lot of kind of getting lost and faffing around. By 4 o'clock in the next morning, these empty taxis reach a place called Damata, which is northeast of Paris. There's nothing there.
我必须说，司机们对此感到非常非常不高兴。他们对失去车费感到不高兴。他们也对开着车灯开车感到不高兴，因为他们说，好吧，我们只会撞到彼此，事实上他们中的许多人确实也这么做了。总之，在经历了大量迷路和瞎忙之后。到了第二天早上4点，这些空出租车到达了一个叫达马尔（Damata）的地方，那是巴黎的东北部。那里什么都没有。
There's nobody there to meet them. So the drivers just get out and lounge around in the sunshine because it's a sunny day. And a nice detail, past them go loads of blokes on bicycles heading to the front. and the drivers all shout, Vively cyclist, Vively cyclist, whatever. That must have been inspiring to see taxi shouting,
那里没有人迎接他们。所以司机们只是下车，在阳光下闲逛，因为那天阳光明媚。还有一个很好的细节，大量骑自行车的家伙从他们身边经过，前往前线。司机们都大喊：骑行者万岁，骑行者万岁，诸如此类。看到出租车司机在大喊大叫，一定很鼓舞人心，
as he's lying there with like a bottle of wine on the verge of the road eating his cheese. Anyway, they're eventually redirected to a railway siding near a village called La Barrier, and here they find their men,
当他躺在路边的草地上，手里拿着一瓶酒，吃着奶酪时。不管怎样，他们最终被重新指派到巴里耶（La Barrier）村附近的一个铁路支线，在这里他们找到了他们的人，
their passengers, and these are the men of the 103th and 14th infantry brigades. And the soldiers, the men, cannot believe. leave it when the taxes turn up. Because in 1914, you only took a taxi if you were rich. Taxes are a luxury. And what is more, of course, most of these men have never been in a car of
他们的乘客，这些人是第103和第14步兵旅的士兵。当出租车出现时，士兵们简直不敢相信。因为在1914年，只有有钱人才会坐出租车。出租车是一种奢侈品。而且更重要的是，当然，这些士兵大多数从来没有坐过任何一种汽车。
any kind. So it's very exciting. They get into these cars. There's now, the convoy is swollen to about 400 vehicles. This is the first instalments of the taxis. And there's other vehicles, too. So they've managed to rope in some buses. They've got some limousines. And they've even got a couple of racing cars. I mean, imagine going to the front of a racing car. I love the contribution of the Grand Prix to the war effort. So there's the guy who's driving Joff around and now they're driving soldiers up to the front. There's magnificent reflection on French sport. And cyclists, right? Yeah, them as well. Vively cycliste. Great stuff. So the soldiers have been on the road, you know, on the train for ages. So they're knackered. Most of them try to sleep in the cars.
所以这非常令人兴奋。他们上了这些车。现在，车队已经膨胀到大约400辆车。这是第一批出租车。还有其他车辆。所以他们设法拉拢了一些公共汽车。他们有一些豪华轿车。他们甚至还有几辆赛车。我的意思是，想象一下坐着赛车去前线。我喜欢大奖赛对战争努力的贡献。所以有那个载着霞飞到处跑的家伙，现在他们正开车把士兵送上前线。这是对法国体育的壮丽反思。还有骑自行车的人，对吧？是的，他们也是。骑行者万岁。太棒了。所以士兵们已经在路上，你知道的，在火车上待了很久。所以他们累垮了。他们大多数人试图在车里睡觉。
It's very difficult actually because it's an incredibly unrelaxing journey. The, the Cars, because they've got the headlights off, they keep bumping into each other, they keep getting flat tires, they keep getting lost and breaking down. Anyway, you asked how long it was, Tom, and actually, I'm going to give you the detail now. I'm not going to make you join the rest of history club. It's 30 miles. It's 30 miles. They've gone 30 miles, so as dawn is breaking on the 8th of September, they reach this village called Nontoi, which will be pleased to hear, because I know you're a big fan of this organization, is near Disneyland Paris today. But presumably not then.
实际上这非常困难，因为这是一段极其不放松的旅程。由于这些汽车都关了大灯，它们不断地撞在一起，不断地爆胎，不断地迷路和抛锚。总之，你问过多长时间，汤姆，实际上，我现在要告诉你细节。我不会让你加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部的。是30英里。是30英里。他们走了30英里，因此当9月8日的黎明破晓时，他们到达了一个叫南图瓦（Nontoi）的村庄，你听到会很高兴，因为我知道你是这个组织的超级粉丝，它今天就在巴黎迪士尼乐园附近。但当时大概不在。
they should have a ride. It'd be a brilliant ride, the Texas of the Marne ride, wouldn't it? First World War theme park. Actually, they have that theme park. Pidufu. You know that place where you can go and do, there's like Verdun and stuff?
他们应该去坐一次过山车。那会是一个很棒的游乐项目，马恩河出租车游乐项目，对吧？第一次世界大战主题公园。实际上，他们有那个主题公园。狂人国（Puy du Fou）。你知道那个你可以去玩的地方吗，那里有凡尔登之类的东西？
Yes, and gladiators and things. Yeah, it's run by, it's run by like monarchists, French monarchists or something. Dominic, if only you knew someone at Disney and you could get them to do a miracle of the Marne ride. Bob, if you're listening, you know what to do.
是的，还有角斗士之类的地方。是的，它是由，它是由保皇党经营的，法国保皇党什么的。多米尼克，你要是认识迪士尼的人，能让他们做一个马恩河奇迹的游乐项目就好了。鲍勃，如果你在听，你知道该怎么做。
You know what to do. They're going to call us. Exactly. Right. Anyway, so basically they've reached Disneyland. They decant the soldiers and now the soldiers can take their place on the front line to defend their homeland. And the reason we've spent so much time on this story is that this in France becomes probably the great legend of the First World War, a symbol of patriotic solidarity, a sign of the determination of the French people to drive the invaders from their sacred homeland, all of this kind of stuff. And the story kind of spread in the years after the world, but it really was turbocharged in the 1950s. There's a writer called Jean Dutour who wrote a book called The Taxes of the Man. And he said, and I quote, that this was the single greatest event of the 20th century,
你知道该怎么做。他们会给我们打电话的。没错。好吧。不管怎样，基本上他们已经到达了迪士尼乐园。他们让士兵下车，现在士兵们可以在前线占领他们的位置来保卫他们的祖国。我们花这么多时间在这个故事上的原因，是这在法国成为了第一次世界大战中可以说是最伟大的传奇，是爱国团结的象征，是法国人民将侵略者赶出他们神圣祖国的决心的标志，诸如此类的东西。这个故事在世界大战后的几年里流传开来，但在20世纪50年代确实得到了极大的推动。有一个作家叫让·迪图尔（Jean Dutour），他写了一本书叫《马恩河的出租车》。他说，我引用他的话，这是20世纪唯一最伟大的事件，
which is a big claim. Greater than the Angels of Monce, surely not. Even greater, I think, than the Angels of Monce, Tom. And I think it's interesting because he wrote that in 1956. And the context of that was that France had just been kicked out of Vietnam. They'd lost at Diembeen Fu. Things have just kicked off in Algeria. They're obviously still very bruised after Second World War and the humiliation in 1940.
这是一个很大的说法。比蒙斯天使还要伟大，简直不可能。汤姆，我认为甚至比蒙斯天使还要伟大。我认为这很有趣，因为他在1956年写下了这句话。这背后的背景是法国刚刚被赶出越南。他们在奠边府战败了。阿尔及利亚的事情刚刚爆发。在经历了第二次世界大战和1940年的屈辱之后，他们显然仍然饱受创伤。
And people were desperate for going to patriotic consolation. So the story of the taxis of the Marne became incredibly important to them. And if you go to the Army Museum at Lesain Valide, I'm sure Theo is there all the time. They have a very handsome, old, Cunot taxi with, I almost said that in a French way. That was weird. Yeah, you did. Yeah. Yeah.
人们渴望获得爱国主义的慰藉。因此，马恩河出租车的故事对他们来说变得极其重要。如果你去荣军院的军事博物馆，我确信西奥（Theo）一直都在那里。他们有一辆非常漂亮的、旧的雷诺出租车，我差点用法国口音说出那个词。那太奇怪了。是的，你确实说了。是啊。是啊。
It's getting more of a... One more fact of the phone as you go on. Exactly. Inspector Cluzzo joins us now on the rest of history. It's got a red body and yellow wheels. And it's registration. Do you know it's registration? Of course you do.
随着你的继续，它变得越来越...克卢梭探长现在加入了我们的“历史其余部分”。它有一个红色的车身和黄色的车轮。它的车牌号。你知道它的车牌号吗？你当然知道。
It's 2862G7. Is that significant? No. It's just an interesting fact. You just knew that. I think that's a single most boring fact we've ever had on the rest of history. No.
它是2862G7。这有什么意义吗？没有。这只是一个有趣的事实。你刚好知道这一点。我认为这是我们在“历史其余部分”节目中听过的最无聊的事实。不。
No, I tell you the worst fact, the fact that you wanted to cut out, General Cuth's... Father's beard. Oh, this is even more boring than that. No, no, no, no. But the whole story is incredible, right? And I'm wondering if, as with the Angels of Mons,
不，我告诉你最糟糕的事实，就是你想剪掉的那个事实，库斯（Cuth）将军的...父亲的胡子。哦，这比那个还要无聊。不，不，不，不。但整个故事令人难以置信，对吧？我想知道，正如蒙斯天使一样，
whether there have been skeptics and people who've doubted its veracity and whether it actually mattered at all. Oh, well, hold on. Nobody doubts its ferocity. So this is the difference with the Angels of Mons. It definitely happened. There's no question about that. However, did it make any difference at all?
是否一直存在怀疑论者和怀疑其真实性的人，以及它是否真的重要。哦，好吧，等等。没有人怀疑它的激烈程度。所以这与蒙斯天使的不同之处在于。它确实发生了。这是毫无疑问的。然而，它真的有什么区别吗？
None whatsoever to the story. It's completely inconsequential. So basically, the tax is transported about 4,000 men out of a million. And the idea that it's this sort of hurrah, hurrah, very Hollywood, kind of rousing music, everybody's shaking hands and saying, Vive la France, is not really right. The driver has spent the entire time complaining. They basically kept saying, are we going to be paid for this? I'm not doing this for free.
对历史没有任何影响。这完全是无关紧要的。所以基本上，出租车运送了大约4000人，而总人数有一百万。那种充满欢呼、非常荷里活风格、令人振奋的音乐、每个人都在握手并高呼“法兰西万岁”的想法，其实并不太准确。司机们把所有时间都花在抱怨上了。他们基本上一直在说，我们能拿到钱吗？我可不是白干的。
So are the meters on? They kept the meters running. Of course they get the meters running. And the French government eventually agreed. that they would pay them a quarter of the amount on the meter. They were paid 130 francs, which is the equivalent of a fortnight's wages, which is not
所以计价器开着吗？他们一直开着计价器。当然，他们让计价器一直走字。法国政府最终同意了。他们会支付计价器上四分之一的金额。他们获得了130法郎的报酬，这相当于两周的工资，这还算不错。
bad. And it's better than being shot, isn't it? It is better. Getting horrible blisters. And the thing about the First World War is everybody thinks of it as it's all very boring and it's about munitions and barbed wire and trenches. In reality, the First World War is an absolute kind of, it's fertile
而且总比挨枪子强，不是吗？确实更好。免得长满可怕的水泡。关于第一次世界大战的一点是，每个人都认为它非常无聊，全都是关于军火、铁丝网和战壕。实际上，第一次世界大战绝对是一种，它是神话、传奇、爱国发明的肥沃土地，所有这些东西。这就是我们将在关于蒙斯时代的番外中探讨的内容。超自然的东西在人们思考第一次世界大战的方式中扮演了重要角色，例如，因为这是精神主义的时代。不管怎样，让我们回到地球。前线发生了什么？
territory for myths, for legends, for patriotic inventions, all of this stuff. This is what we'll be exploring in our bonus on the age of Le Mans. The supernatural stuff plays a big part in the way people think about the first world for example because it's the age of spiritualism. Anyway, let's get back to planet Earth. What has been happening at the front?
你在上半场的结尾描述了风暴是如何在9月6日开始时爆发的。所有这成百上千万的法国人和超过10万名英国人，带着3000门重型火炮，在这个从巴黎一直延伸到东部凡尔登的庞大前线上向前冲锋。实际上，那个体现了那天精神的人，是一个在如今法国不太受重视的人，他就是未来的顶级卖国贼菲利普·贝当（Philippe Petin），
You described at the end of the first half how the storm had broken at the beginning of the 6th of September. All of these hundreds and hundreds of thousands of Frenchmen and more than 100,000 Britons armed with 3,000 heavy guns charging forward on this vast front line that goes from in Paris all the way to Verdun in the east. And actually, the person who probably incarnates the spirit of that day is a man who's not well regarded in France these days, who is the future top collaborator, Philippe Petin,
实际上他也是伟大战争的超级明星。贝当在6日的黎明告诉他的士兵，他说，好了，我们要向这个村庄圣邦特（Saint-Bont）推进。他的士兵们，是的，他们累了，他们焦虑了，他们犹豫了。贝当下了马，他走到前线，加入了他的步兵，他说，我将亲自领导你们，他亲自带领他们走向前线。所以在其他情况下，这将是一个非常鼓舞人心的故事，法国的每个人都会知道。但不幸的是，贝当在20世纪40年代有点让人失望了，所以它没有像它本来应该的那样受到赞誉。
who is a great star, actually, of the Great War. Petin, adorn on the 6th, told his men, he said, right, we're going to advance on this village, Saint-Bont. And his men, yeah, they're tired, they're anxious, they hesitated. Peyton got off his horse, he went up to the front line, joined his infantry, and he said, I will lead you personally, and he personally led them towards the front. So in other circumstances, it would be a very inspiring story, and everybody in France would know about it. But unfortunately, Payton had rather let himself down in 1940s, so it's not as celebrated as he might be.
在1914年，拿破仑式的激情。是的，完全是，这就是你想要的。但这够吗？你知道，我们，边界战役的教训难道不是爱国激情并不够吗，你知道的，除了战斗精神之外，还需要大量的工业实力。嗯，大概你需要，你需要一个好的战略，你需要一个好的时机。确实如此。现在，马恩河战役的问题在于它是如此宏大，以至于它实际上并不是一场真正的战役。它是几场同时进行的战役。有趣的是，前线某个部分的军官通常根本不知道其他地方发生了什么。所以在某些地方，法国人实际上做得很好。所以，例如，在，如果你想象在西侧，
In 1914, Napoleonic Ella. Yeah, totally, is what you want. But is it enough? you know, we've, surely the lesson of the battle of the frontiers is that patriotic ala is not, you know, you have to, there's a lot of industrial might that is required alongside sort of fighting spirit. Well, presumably that you need, you need a good strategy and you need good timing. You do indeed. Now, the thing with the Battle of the Marne is it is so vast that it actually isn't really one battle. It's several battles going on simultaneously. And the interesting thing is that officers in one part of the front generally have no idea what's going on elsewhere. So in some places the French actually do very well. So, for example, on the, if you imagine in the West side,
法国第五军狠狠地痛击了卡尔·冯·比洛（Karl von Bulow）的德国第二军。与此同时，英国人实际上几乎在毫无阻碍地推进，进入了德国第二军和第一军之间的这个关键缺口。也就是冯·比洛和冯·克拉克（von Cluck）之间。所以在马克斯·黑斯廷斯（Max Hastings）的书里有一个精彩的细节。他记录了列奥纳尔·丁尼生（Lionel Tennyson）中尉，他不仅是诗人丁尼生的孙子，后来还成为了英格兰板球队长。
the French Fifth Army absolutely batters Karl von Boulof's German Second Army. At the same time, the British are advancing actually almost unchallenged into this crucial gap between the German second and first army. So that's von Boulogne and von Cluck. So there's a brilliant detail in Max Hastings book. He records Lieutenant Lionel Tennyson, who was not only the grandson of the poet Tennyson, but also becomes some England cricket captain.
他说，当法国人与德国人激烈交战时，我们路过了吉米·罗斯柴尔德（Jimmy Rothschild）漂亮的房子，看到到处都是成群的野鸡在跑来跑去，渴望能停下来抓几只。然后另一个细节是另一个家伙报道的，再次引用马克斯·黑斯廷斯的话，看到路上散落着武器和装备，埃金顿——所以这就是看到这一幕的家伙——感到着迷，也相当震惊，因为被遗弃的德国车辆之一被证明装满了女性内衣。哇。你看，我认为英国人有正确的态度。他们在进行大量的战斗，但又没有太多。
And he says that while the French are furiously fighting the Germans, we passed Jimmy Rothschild's beautiful house and saw masses of pheasants running about everywhere and longed to be able to stop and get some. And then another detail that this is reported by some other guy, quoting Max Hastings again, Seeing the road littered with weapons and equipment, Egington, so this is the guy who sees it, was fascinated and rather shocked that one of the abandoned German vehicles proved to be laden with women's underwear. Wow. See, I think the British have the right attitude. They're doing a lot of fighting, but not too much.
你知道，他们还在闲逛，视察野鸡什么的还有内衣。但实际上，盟军并没有事事顺心，因为在东部，他们干得很糟糕。德国人在南锡（Nonsie）和凡尔登险些突破防线。而在中心，局势非常非常紧张。在那里，指挥第九军（法国人）的斐迪南·福煦（Ferdinand Foch）正在对付德国第三军。情况非常棘手。这就是福煦向霞飞发送法国历史上最著名的信息之一的时候。
You know, they're also strolling around kind of inspecting pheasants and whatever and underwear. But actually, the Allies don't have things all their own way, because in the East, they do quite badly. The Germans are quite close to breaking through at Nonsie and at Verdun. and in the centre things are very, very tight. So there, Ferdinand Foch, who is commanding the 9th Army, the French, is taking on the German Third Army. It's very dicey. It's when Foch sends Jof one of the most famous messages in French history.
我的中心告急，我的右翼后撤，局势极佳，我进攻。我的中心在让步，我的右翼在撤退，局势极佳，我要进攻。这种，你知道的，那种同时在后退和前进的结合，就是整个战役的缩影，因为在9月8日的早晨，
My centre said, my right recule, situation excellent, I attack. My centre is giving way, my right is retreating, situation, excellent, I'm going to attack. and that sort of you know the sort of combination of like you're going backwards and going forwards at the same time is the whole battle in microcosm because on the morning of the 8th of September
德国人对福煦的右翼发动了猛烈的刺刀冲锋，他们把法军逼退了大约八英里，但德国人实在是太累了，推进了八英里后他们就停下来了，他们大多数人只是坐下来然后开始睡觉，他们停了一秒钟，
the Germans launched this massive bayonet charge against Foch's right and they pushed them about eight miles back but the Germans were so tired that after eight miles it just stopped and most of them just sat down and started went to sleep they stopped for a second
他们累得精疲力竭，直接就睡着了。但福煦的士兵们，你本以为他们现在会抓住优势，他们同样精疲力竭。而且这时候天气也变了，这实际上是这个故事的关键部分。天气变了。开始下雨了。变得非常起雾。所以法国人实际上根本不知道他们在哪里。
and they were so exhausted They just fell asleep. But Foch's men, who would think would now seize the advantage, they are equally shattered. And also by now the weather has changed, which is actually a crucial part of this story. The weather changes. It starts raining. It becomes very foggy. So the French have no idea actually where they are.
字面上的战争迷雾。战争迷雾，完全正确。所以真的，马恩河的故事，胜利与其说是在战场上赢得的，不如说是在头脑中赢得的。这基本上是一场意志力的考验。你认为你赢了吗，还是不赢？或者你打算退让吗？德国人的问题在于他们的通讯太糟糕了。所以在西侧，这两个极其重要的军队——冯·克拉克的第一军和冯·比洛的第二军，
Literally the fog of war. The fog of war, exactly. So really, the story of the man, the victory is not won so much on the battlefield is in the head. It's basically a test of nerve. Do you think you're winning or not? or are you going to give way? And the problem for the Germans is their communications are terrible. So on the western side, these two really important armies, von Klux's first army and von Boulog's
直到9月9日晚些时候，两者之间才建立直接的电缆连接。所以这两位指挥官根本不知道对方在哪里，在做什么，他们有点在各自为战。而最高指挥官，赫尔穆特·冯·毛奇（Helmut von Moltke），你知道的，以前很斯巴达，很忧郁，总是想着转世，他远在150英里外的卢森堡。他其实根本不知道发生了什么，只能研究那些电报报告，变得非常焦虑。他向西派出了一个非常非常重要的人物，一个名不见经传的中校，名叫理查德·亨施（Richard Hensch）。战后，美国参谋长说，盟军应该建造一个名人堂，为亨施建立一座雕像，并把它放在显眼的位置，这似乎非常奇怪，但我会准确解释原因。亨施是个非常聪明的人，作为德国总参谋部的一名情报军官，毛奇一直把他当作派往所有将军的特使。
second army, there is no direct cable link between the two until late on the 9th of September. So the two commanders have no idea where the other one is and what is doing, and they're sort of fighting separate battles. And the Supreme Commander, Helmut von Moltke, you know, formerly Spar, Obitue, very depressed, thinking about reincarnation, he's 150 miles away in Luxembourg. And he has no idea really what's going on, sort of studying, you know, wire, sort of wire reports and getting very anxious. And he sends West a really, really important figure who's an obscure lieutenant colonel called Richard Hensch. And after the war, the American chief of staff said that the allies should build a hall of fame and build a statue to Hensch and give it pride of place, which seems very peculiar, but I'll explain exactly why that is. Hensh is a very smart guy, as an intelligence officer who works for the German general staff, and Malka has been using him as an emissary to all his generals.
到了9月8日，也就是战斗开始两三天后，毛奇陷入了巨大的恐慌中，他说，我要派亨施去前线同克拉克和比洛谈谈。亨施来到德国第二军的指挥部，在那里他发现这个该死比洛正处于极度恐慌中。所以第二军陷入了真正的麻烦。
And by the 8th of September, so a couple of days, two or three days into the fighting, Mulk has got in a massive panic, and he says, I'm going to send Hensh to the front to talk. to Kluk and Bulov. Hensh goes to the headquarters of the German Second Army and there he finds this public Bulov in a massive funk. So the second armies are in a real trouble.
比洛说，我的部队筋疲力尽。盟军有突破缺口的危险。比洛本人状态糟糕透顶。像所有的，首先，将军们，他已经68岁了，他有严重的甲状腺问题，还有严重的动脉粥样硬化。你们当中有谁是这样吗？他没有某种致命疾病。我不这么认为。我认为其性质在于，直到你60多岁时，你才会成为那种最高指挥官类型的人。而在那个时候，人们的生活方式非常不健康，我想，可能吧。他们一直在喝很多优质葡萄酒，这并没有给他们带来什么好处。
Budov says, my troops are exhausted. The Allies are in danger of breaking through the gaps. Budov himself is in a terrible state. Like all, first of all, General's, he's got 68, he's got massive thyroid
8日晚些时候，在与亨施交谈时，比洛开始收到前线的这些更多报告。盟军正在突破，他对亨施说，我的军队正在化为灰烬。我们面临着彻底的灾难。亨施对他说，好吧，听着，毛奇已经授权我对你说，如果你想撤退，由你决定。这是德国军队中第一次真正谈论撤退。所以这是一个具有里程碑意义的时刻。他们没有立即做出决定，但一夜之间，情绪变得越来越黯淡。
problems and he's got severe arterioschlorosis. Is there any of you? He doesn't have a kind of fatal illness. I don't think so. I think because the nature of it is you don't become a sort of Supreme Commander-type person, till you're in your late 60s. And at that point, people have had a very unhealthy lifestyle, I think, probably. There's been drinking a lot of fine wines, and it hasn't done them any good.
比洛三次泪流满面，说，你知道的，我应付不了这个。就像，我压力太大了，我们要输了。我的人都要死了，诸如此类的事情。早上5点，他们得到空中侦察报告说法国人越来越近了。所以在早上9点，事实上是9点零2分，我们喜欢法医般的事实。亨施对比洛说，好吧，好吧，做决定吧，撤退。于是，神经基本上已经崩溃的比洛下达了第二军撤退的命令。现在亨施继续他在前线的驾驶之旅，这是德国军事史上最灾难性的驾驶。
Late on the 8th, while he's talking to Hensch, Boulof starts to get these more reports in the front. The Allies are breaking through, and he says to Hensh, my army's being reduced to cinders. We're facing total catastrophe. And Hensch says to him, well, look, Malka has given me authority to say to you, if you want to retreat, it's your call. And this is the first time that anybody in the German army has really talked about retreating. So this is a kind of landmark moment. They don't make the decision straight away, but overnight, the mood gets bleaker and bleaker.
他向西行驶了50英里，来到亚历山大·冯·克拉克第一军的指挥部。这是一次可怕的旅程。道路上挤满了吓坏了的难民。到处都是精疲力竭、受伤的士兵。有大量的火炮。有伤员，你知道的，有躺在沟渠里的人等等。这完全是一个战区。在各个点上，他的车实际上受到了自己人的攻击，因为太混乱了。
Three times, Buleoff breaks down and floods of tears, says, you know, I can't cope with this. Like, I'm too stressed, we're going to lose. My men are all going to die, all this kind of thing. And at 5 o'clock in the morning, they get reports from air reconnaissance that the French are coming ever closer. And so at 9 o'clock in the morning, at 9.02, in fact, we love a forensic fact. Hensh says to Boulof, okay, fine, make the call, retreat. So Boulof, whose nerve is basically snapped now, issues the order for his second army to retreat. So now Hensk continues his driving tour of the front, the most disastrous drive in German military history.
秩序已经崩溃。他抵达第一军指挥部。当他到达时，第一军的军官实际上相当自信。他们说，是的，英国人已经进来了，但我们认为我们能应付英国人。我们以前应付过他们。亨施说，不，不，不，第二军已经在撤退了。所以你们可能也需要撤退。第一军的军官惊呆了。他们像是在说，什么？我们认为我们能赢。他说，不，不，不，毛奇告诉我有权做出这些决定。你知道的，你们应该撤退。所以当他回到卢森堡时，
He drives 50 miles west to the headquarters of Alexander von Clux's First Army. It's a terrible journey. The roads are clogged with terrified refugees. There are exhausted and wounded soldiers everywhere. There's loads of artillery. There are wounded, you know, there's kind of men lying in the ditches, whatnot. It's a complete war zone. And at various points, his car actually comes under attack from his own side because it's so confused.
决定其实已经做出了。当天晚些时候，法军推进到了第二军曾经所在的地方，一个叫蒙米赖（Montmirai）的地方，当他们到达那里时，他们大吃一惊，因为那里什么都没有。冯·比洛的第二军已经消失了。在他们身后，他们留下了散落着垃圾的田野，包括数量惊人的空酒瓶，这可能说明了问题。德国人在战线后方度过了一段美好的时光。第二天，即10日，更西边的故事也是如此。所以马克斯·黑斯廷斯引用了一个名叫保罗·兰蒂尔（Paul Lantier）的炮手的话，他在我们上次谈到的阿登地区的凡尔登大屠杀中幸存下来，这个叫兰蒂尔的部队醒来后发现这真的很奇怪。鸟儿在歌唱，阳光在照耀，没有大炮，一队法国步兵走过，这个单位行进中的上校大喊，
And the order is broken down. He arrives at First Army headquarters. When he gets there, the first army officers are actually quite. confident. They say, yeah, the British should come in, but we reckon we can handle the British. We've handled them before. And Hensh says, no, no, no, the second army is already retreating. So you probably need to fall back too. And the first army officers are stunned. They're like, what? We think we can win this. And he says, no, no, no, Malka has told me I've got authority to make these decisions. You know, you should pull back. So by the time he goes back to Luxembourg,
我们赢了。德国人在全线撤退。兰蒂尔事后说，消息口口相传，让我们欣喜若狂。胜利，胜利，而我们原本是如此不抱希望。所以德国人崩溃了。法国人赢了。对法国人来说，这成了一个绝对传奇的时刻。它获得了一种神圣的地位，被称为“马恩河上的奇迹”。而真正创造这个词的人，不幸的是在年底时，是一个极右翼、反犹太主义作家，名叫莫里斯·巴雷斯（Maurice Bages）。
the decision has actually been made. And later that day, the French advanced on where the Second Army had been, a place called Montmirai, and they're astounded when they get there because there's nothing there. Von Bulow's Second Army has vanished. In their wake, they've left fields of strewn with rubbish, including an unbelievable quantity of empty wine bottles, which probably tells its own story. The Germans have had a fine old time in the back of the battle. The next day, the 10th, is the same story further west. So Max Hastings quotes a gunner called Paul Lantier who had survived the slaughter at Verton
他基本上说，马恩河上的奇迹，你知道的，你在蒙斯天使的番外中谈到的这个超自然元素，对法国那些非常右翼的极右翼作家来说非常重要。他说这是，
in the Ardenne that we talked about last time this bloat Lantier's unit they wake up and they just find it's really weird. The birds are singing the sun is shining, there's no guns and a load of French infantry march passed and the colonel of this unit marching past shouts
我将马恩河上的奇迹与——我引用他的话——永恒的法兰西奇迹、圣女贞德的奇迹联系起来。那种认为在绝境中上帝会以某种方式干预并拯救法国免受侵略者侵害的想法。我的意思是，实际上，当然，真正值得赞扬的人是，
we've won. The Germans are retreating all across the line. Nantier said afterwards the news as it passed from mouth to mouth shook us with joy. Victory, victory, when we were so far from expecting it. So the Germans have cracked. The French have won. And for the French, this becomes an absolutely legendary moment. It achieves a kind of sacred status as the miracle on the man. And the guy who actually coined that expression, unfortunately, at the end of the year, was an ultra-nationalist, anti-Semitic writer called Maurice Bages.
A，法国士兵，B，加利埃尼和霞飞，他们在关键时刻没有像他们的继任者在1940年那样惊慌失措。特别是霞飞，当他坐在那里吃着他那顿丰盛的午餐时，他选择了正确的反击时机。我的意思是，他对时机的把握是完美的。但如果你阅读关于马恩河的大多数记载，实际上大多数历史学家对法军做对了什么不太感兴趣，而对德军做错了什么更感兴趣。你可以责怪个别将军改变了计划，但我认为大多数历史学家会说真正的问题实际上在于整个概念，施里芬计划（The Schleifen plan），施里芬计划（Schleifens），施里芬和毛奇计划。这个为期六周的时间表是如此不切实际，以至于除非盟军惊慌失措并失去理智，否则它几乎不可能奏效。
And he basically said the miracle on the Marn, you know, this element that you talked about in the angels of Mont's bonus, the supernatural, very important to sort of very right-wing ultra-nationalist writers in France. And he said this is,
基本上，如果盟军保持冷静，德国人的这台庞然大物最终总会散架。那我能问一下，是不是有一种感觉，德军对这个计划的执着意味着他们在临场应变方面不如原本那样灵活了？这是一个有趣的问题，因为，当然，当他们开始临场应变时，事情就出错。当他们开始改变计划时，我认为事实的真相是，德国的计划诞生于一个真正糟糕的战略地位，那就是你被夹在法国和俄罗斯之间。所以他们可能是对的，唯一的——我的意思是，我想他们本可以坐视不管，进行一场防守战，等待盟军的进攻，但是我的意思是谁愿意在两线作战中遭到进攻呢？我认为他们在进攻战中这可能是他们取胜的唯一途径，但这只是一场巨大无比的赌博。我的意思是，如果他们，你知道的，如果他们坚持最初的计划而不是即兴发挥，会不会效果更好？但即兴发挥是由这样一个事实强迫他们的：
I associate the miracle in the Marn with, and I quote, the eternal French miracle, the miracle of Joan of Arc. The idea that, you know, in extremists, somehow God will intervene and he will save France from the invaders. I mean, actually, of course, the people who really deserve the credit,
这个计划根本无法坚持下去。是的，我认为在某种程度上你是完全正确的，
A, the French soldiers, and B, Galiini and Jophe, who in the crucial moment had not panicked, as their successors panicked in 1940. And Jophe, in particular, when he's sitting there eating his enormous lunches, he has chosen the right moment to strike back. I mean, his grasp of timing was perfect. But if you read most accounts of them on, actually most historians are less interested in what the French got right and more interested in what the Germans got wrong. You could blame the individual generals for changing their plan, but I think most historians would say the real problem is actually with the whole concept, the Schleifen plan, the Schlefenm, the Schlef and Molka plan. This idea of the six-week timetable was so unrealistic that there's probably no way that it could have worked unless the Allies panicked and lost their nerve.
他们不得不开始即兴发挥。而且我认为也许还有一个心理因素，回到你的问题。我想如果你被告知，我们必须在六周内完成这个，这是唯一能做到的计划，当计划开始出错时，就会产生巨大的恐慌，是的。
that basically if the allies kept their call, the wheels were always going to come off, the German juggernaut. So can I ask, is there a sense perhaps that the commitment on the German part to this plan means that they are less able to kind of think on their feet than they would otherwise have been? It's an interesting question because, of course, when they do think on their feet, it goes wrong. When they start to change the plan, I think that the truth of the matter is that the German plan is born of a really poor, strategic position, which is your sandwich between France and Russia. And so they're probably right that the only, I mean, I suppose they could have just sat and done a defensive war and waited to be attacked by the Allies, but I mean,
嗯，这正是发生的事情。所以我认为德国人在心理上受到的打击可能比盟军在边界战役撤退时受到的打击要大得多。嗯，英国人喜欢撤退，
who wants to be attacked on two fronts? I think they were probably right that in an offensive war, this was the only way they could win, but it's just a massive, massive gamble. I mean, if they, you know, would it have worked better if they had stuck to the original and not improvised? But the improvisations are forced on them by the fact that. the plan is simply impossible to stick to. Yeah, I think to some extent you're absolutely right,
不是吗？你会喜欢往后退，因为你知道那样你会赢。好吧，你先输，然后你撤退，然后你赢。没错。这就是所有英国历史的故事。因为你所有的那些记录，
that they have to start improvising. And I think as well maybe there is a psychological element to go back to your question. I think if you have been told, we have to do this in six weeks and this is the only plan that will do it, when the plan starts to go wrong, massive panic, yeah.
那些日记和信件，德国军官在交谈时说，你知道的，人们在哭泣，他们崩溃了，他们糊涂了，所有这些类的事情。我的意思是，这是一个关键的事情，我认为从长远来看，这在德国历史上非常非常重要。
Well, this is exactly what happens. So I think the Germans are probably psychologically much more shaken by their retreat from the Battle of the Marne than the Allies were by their retreat from the Battle of the Frontiers. Well, the British love a retreat,
在这个时候，他们并不认为自己正在失败。马恩河战役中的很多人认为他们正在赢，或者至少他们守住了阵地。当他们接到向后撤退的命令时，他们并不觉得这是一支被打败的军队。所以我认为实际上正是在这里，在战争爆发一个月后，你萌生了一种非常有害的政治迷因的起源，我想，这就是我们被背叛的想法。我们被出卖了。好吧，所以是背后捅刀？我们被高层的悲观主义者在背后捅了刀子。现在，在这个时候，他们并没有用如此明确的术语来谈论，而且他们显然
don't they? You'd be like going backwards because you know you're going to win that way. Well, you lose first, and then you retreat and then you win. Exactly. That's the story of all British history. Because all the accounts
没有在谈论，你知道的，共产主义者、犹太人以及他们在第一次世界大战结束时指责的其他人。但确实有这种感觉：我们本该赢的。你知道的，我们理应获得胜利。出于某种原因，它被剥夺了。多米尼克，凯撒大帝在这其中扮演了什么角色？他在和毛奇厮混吗？凯撒在后面闲逛。
that you have, the sort of diaries and letters, German officers are talking, and they say, you know, people are crying, they're devastated, they're confused, all of this kind of thing. I mean, here's a key thing, and I think it's really, really important in the long run in German history.
显然，他和任何人一样感到困惑、迷茫和愤怒，尽管他不像冯·毛奇那样彻底崩溃，因为冯·毛奇正如我们所说，有病而且抑郁，基本上总是处于崩溃的边缘，我的意思是，他把这整件事看得极其糟糕。事实上，在战役期间，在这个时期，他一直在给他的妻子写这些非同寻常的信。
At this point, they didn't think they were losing. A lot of people in the Battle of the Month thought they were winning, or that at least they were holding their own. They didn't feel like a beaten army when they got the orders to go backwards. So I think it's actually here, a month into the war, that you have in embryo the origin of a very poisonous political meme, I suppose, which is the idea we've been betrayed. We've been cheated. Okay, so stab in the back? We've been stabbed in the back by defeatists in high places. Now, at this point, they're not talking in such explicit terms, and they're obviously
我找不到词语来形容过去几天压在我肩上的沉重责任感。我们目前处境的骇人困难像一道黑色的帘幕一样挂在我的眼前，透过它我什么也看不到。全世界都在结盟与我们为敌。似乎每个国家都一心要彻底摧毁德国。它们非常顾影自怜，但实际上也有很多负罪感。他说，一想到有多少德国人死去，我就感到恶心。恐怖经常向我袭来，当我想到这一点时，我觉得我必须对这场恐怖负责。
not talking about, you know, communists, Jews, all the rest that they blame at the end of the First World War. But there is this sense, we should have won. You know, we deserved victory. And for some reason, it has been denied us. And Dominic, where is the Kaiser in all this? Is he hanging out with Molka? The Kaiser's hanging around at the back.
我的意思是，作为你的最高指挥官，这很不理想。是的，这不太好吧？当人们去他在卢森堡的指挥部时，他们对所看到的一切感到震惊。我的意思是，一次又一次，人们说，天哪，他是个废人。他是一个心碎的人。有一个叫卡尔·艾内姆（Carl Einem）的将军出现了。毛奇只是对他说，天哪，你知道的，怎么会发生这种事？艾内姆对他发了脾气，说，如果你不知道，谁知道？
Obviously, he's as baffled. and as confused and as angry as anybody, although he's not quite as devastated as von Malka is, because von Malka, who as we've said is sickly and depressive and basically always on the brink of a breakdown, I mean, he's really taken this whole business incredibly badly. And in fact, during the battle, during this period, he's been writing these extraordinary letters to his wife.
你应该比任何人都清楚。你怎么能一直呆在卢森堡，任由领导权的缰绳从你手中滑落？所以在马恩河战役几天后，即9月14日，毛奇真的开始崩溃了。他在房间里以非常激动的姿态踱来踱去，通过牙缝吹口哨。基本上，消息传回了柏林。人们对凯撒说，你得解雇他。他必须走。他完全失控了。
I cannot find the words to describe the crushing burden of responsibility that's weighed on my shoulders in the last few days. The appalling difficulties of our present situation hang before my eyes like a dark curtain through which I can see nothing. The whole world is in league against us. It would seem that every country is bent on destroying Germany once and for all. They're very self-pitying, but also there's a lot of guilt, actually. He says I feel sick to think of how many Germans have died. Often terror overcomes me when I think of this, and I have the feeling that I must answer for this horror.
所以在14日晚上，凯撒任命了一名新的最高指挥官，一名新的总参谋长。他是一个冷酷得多的人物。他就是普鲁士战争大臣埃里希·冯·法金汉（Eric von Falkenhyme）。这是一个好名字。我的意思是，我们提到过这个。就像猎鹰俯冲下来一样。没错。现在，他来自一个普鲁士土地拥有者家庭，这意味着他是一个容克（Juncker）贵族。
I mean, this is very sub-ideal from your Supreme Commander. Yeah, that's not great, is it? And when people go to his headquarters in Luxembourg, they're horrified by what they find. I mean, again and again, people say, God, he's a wreck. He's a broken man. There's one general who turns up called Carl Einem. And Malka just says to him, my God, you know, how could this have happened? And Einem loses his temper with him and says, well, if you don't know, who knows?
我的意思是，这对你的最高指挥官来说是非常不理想的。是的，这不太好，对吧？当人们去他在卢森堡的总部时，他们对所看到的一切感到震惊。我的意思是，一次又一次，人们说，天哪，他已经崩溃了。他是一个心碎的人。有个叫卡尔·艾内姆的将军出现了。毛奇对他说，天哪，你知道的，这怎么可能发生？艾内姆对他发脾气说，好吧，如果你不知道，谁知道呢？
You should know better than anybody. How could you have remained in Luxembourg and allowed the reins of leadership to slip from your hands? So a few days after the Battle of the Marne, 14th of September, Malka really starts to lose it. He's sort of pacing up and down the room in a very agitated way, whistling through his teeth. And basically, word gets back to Berlin. People say to the Kaiser, you've got to fire him. He's got to go. He's lost it completely.
你本该比任何人都清楚。你怎么能一直呆在卢森堡，眼睁睁看着领导权从你手中溜走呢？所以在马恩河战役几天后，即9月14日，毛奇真的开始崩溃了。他在房间里焦躁不安地踱来踱去，从牙缝里吹着口哨。基本上，消息传回了柏林。人们对德皇说，你必须解雇他。他必须走。他已经彻底崩溃了。
So on the evening of the 14th, the Kaiser appoints a new Supreme Commander, a new chief of the general staff. And he is a much chillier character. He is the Prussian war minister, Eric von Falkenheim. It's a good name. I mean, we've mentioned this. Like the falcons swooping down. Exactly. Now, he's from a Prussian land-owning family, which means he's a Juncker.
因此，在14日晚上，德皇任命了一位新的最高指挥官，一位新的总参谋长。他是一个性格冷酷得多的人。他就是普鲁士战争大臣埃里希·冯·法金汉。这是个好名字。我的意思是，我们提到过这个。就像猎鹰俯冲下来一样。没错。现在，他来自一个普鲁士地主家庭，这意味着他是个容克贵族。
But actually, unusually, he's quite young for a top general. So he's only 53. And he is greatly disliked by everybody else. It will amaze people to hear. He's a lonely kind of saturnine kind of man, very often. He has death in his eyes. He almost certainly does, cold eyes. Churchill thinks he's brilliant, though, doesn't he?
但实际上，很不寻常的是，作为一名顶级将领，他相当年轻，年仅53岁。而且他极其不受其他人待听。人们听了可能会大吃一惊。他通常是个孤独、阴郁的人，眼神里透着死亡的气息。他几乎肯定有这样的眼神，冷酷的眼神。不过，丘吉尔认为他很聪明，不是吗？
Churchill rates him as the best of the German generals. I think he probably is, actually. I think Falconheim makes a series of pretty decent calls. I think he knows what he's doing. The other generals don't like him for what they call his mocking superiority. So he thinks he's better than they are. The Kaiser likes him, though. I mean, he's spent a lot of time sucking up to the Kaiser.
丘吉尔将他评为德国将领中最优秀的一个。我想他可能真的是这样。我认为法肯海姆做出了许多相当不错的决策。我觉得他很清楚自己在做什么。其他将领不喜欢他，因为他们所说的“嘲讽般的优越感”。也就是说，他觉得自己比他们都高明。不过，凯撒很喜欢他。我的意思是，他花了很多时间去拍凯撒的马屁。
And Falcon Hein, he's smart. He thinks it's always, I always thought it was going to be a long war. He thinks our priority, you know, for Germany is what we have, we hold. We're probably not going to win this on the battlefield. If we win this at all, we'll win it politically. Ideally, we're probably going to have to strike a deal with one of our adversaries, probably Russia. You know, we'll have to fight the Russians to a standstill and then strike a deal with them. But in the short term, obviously the priority is to find a new defensive position.
而且法肯海姆很聪明。他认为这——我一直以为这将是一场持久战。他认为我们的首要任务，你知道的，对德国来说就是“守住我们所拥有的”。我们可能无法在战场上赢得这场战争。如果我们能赢得战争，那也只能通过政治手段。理想情况下，我们可能不得不与我们的某个对手达成交易，很可能是俄国。你知道的，我们得把俄国人打到僵持状态，然后与他们达成协议。但在短期内，显而易见的当务之急是找到一个新的防御阵地。
Now, the Germans, like the British and the French before them, have not lost their cohesion. They retreat in very good order. And they're nowhere near giving up. They're still inside French territory, remember? They still control the industrial northeast of France. They still control the iron ore field of Lorraine, for example. They don't want to give that up. So on the 12th of September, they call a halt just above the River Aene in the northeast of France.
现在，德国人就像此前的英国人和法国人一样，并没有失去凝聚力。他们以极好的秩序撤退。而且他们离放弃还远得很。记住，他们仍然在法国领土内？他们仍然控制着法国东北部的工业区。例如，他们仍然控制着洛林铁矿区。他们不想放弃这些。因此，在9月12日，他们在法国东北部埃纳河上方停下了脚步。
on the long kind of chalk ridge north of the river. And the next day, the French and the British, in pursuit, crossed the river after them. And it's a very cinematic opening to the Battle of the Aine. The British troops are kind of crossing on these pontoon, improvised pontoon bridges in dense fog. It's like the attack by the orcs on Osgiliath in the Return of the King film. Maybe you're not comparing the British to orcs.
在河以北绵延的白垩山脊上。第二天，追击中的法军和英军渡过河去追赶他们。这是埃纳河战役非常具有电影感的一个开端。英国军队在浓雾中通过这些简易的浮桥渡河。这就像《王者归来》电影中半兽人进攻奥斯吉力亚特的场景。也许你不会把英国人比作半兽人。
I'm comparing the use of pontoon bridges and fog. important to put that on the record. But at this point, it has started to rain. So the weather has broken, the summer is over. Now, both sides at this point in previous wars, with it pouring with rain, they're absolutely exhausted. They've been going back and forth across France. In the Great Northern War, which you did recently on the show, they would have gone to winter quarters. Even Charles XIV would have gone to winter quarters.
我在比较浮桥和浓雾的使用。这一点必须记入记录。但就在此时，开始下雨了。所以天气变了，夏天结束了。在以往的战争中，遇到倾盆大雨时，双方都会精疲力竭。他们一直在法国境内来回奔波。在你在节目中最近聊过的大北方战争中，他们本该进入冬季营地了。甚至查理十四世也会进入冬季营地。
But these days, people don't go to winter quarters. They keep going. And one reason for that is basically they don't need supplies. in the same way. They have tinned food. They have bully beef and stuff like that. So they can just stay out there for as long as, you know, throughout the duration. And so it's at the Ayn, this point, in mid-September 1914, that three key features of the first World War really become apparent. So first of all, both sides now are relying very heavily on their artillery. The days of cavalry charges are over. They are pounding each other with shells for hours on end. In some places,
但如今，人们不再去冬营了。他们继续战斗。其中的一个原因基本上是他们不再以同样的方式需要补给。他们有罐头食品。他们有咸牛肉之类的东西。所以他们可以一直待在那里，你知道的，直到战争结束。因此，正是在1914年9月中旬的埃纳河畔，第一次世界大战的三个关键特征真正显现出来。首先，双方现在都非常依赖炮兵。骑兵冲锋的日子已经结束了。他们用炮弹连续数小时互相轰炸。在某些地方，
you know, a shell will be landing every few seconds. So that's number one. And Dominic, the other thing, I'm guessing, you mentioned that this is Chalkland and Chalk is very easy to dig. So do the spades come out at this point and the picks? So digging and it's raining, right? So it's wet, wet chalk, you can dig it quickly. And if you're a German infantryman holding your position under attack from the Allies,
你知道的，每隔几秒钟就会落下炮弹。所以这是第一点。多米尼克，我猜还有一件事，你提到这里是白垩土地，白垩非常容易挖。那么这个时候铲子和十字镐就派上用场了吗？所以要挖土，而且在下雨，对吧？所以是湿的白垩土，你可以很快地挖掘。如果你是一个在盟军进攻下坚守阵地的德国步兵，
the obvious thing to do is to take out your trenching tools. The Germans actually have better trenching tools than the Allies do. they've been practicing digging trenches for the last 10 years and of course they want to hold their positions they're not anticipating moving so they dig very deep and this is one reason why
显而易见的事情就是拿出你的战壕工具。德国人实际上比盟国拥有更好的战壕工具。他们在过去的10里一直都在练习挖战壕，当然他们想要守住阵地，他们没有料到要移动，所以他们挖得很深，这也是为什么
for the whole of the First World War the German trenches are usually better than the British ones the Germans don't want to leave their trenches whereas for example the British or the French their expectation is that they will advance and move on to new positions I've never really thought of that
在整个第一次世界大战期间，德国人的战壕通常比英国人的要好。德国人不想离开他们的战壕，而例如英国人或法国人，他们的期望是他们会前进并转移到新的阵地。我从没真正想过这一点。
I've learned something so oh wow that's you've actually God, Tom, you've actually gained something from the podcast. I have. That's lovely. That's lovely. First time in 700 episodes or whatever. It's a wonderful moment.
我学到了一些东西，哦，哇，你其实——天哪，汤姆，你居然从播客中有所收获。我确实有。这太美妙了。这太美妙了。在700多期节目里还是第一次。这是一个美妙的时刻。
A few times before this, but that's a very good insight. That's a top insight. Well, I mean, it's not my own. It's in every single book about the first world. I know. I know. It just never really registered until I heard it from your lips. Okay.
之前有过几次，但这真的是一个很好的见解。这是一个顶级的见解。好吧，我的意思是，这不是我原创的。每一本关于一战的书里都有。我知道。我知道。只是直到听到你亲口说出来，我才真正意识到这一点。好吧。
Oh, that's lovely. So that means the character of the fighting now has fundamentally changed. Waterloo, 100 years before. done and dusted pretty much in a day. But there's no way that's going to happen again. These battles are going to take weeks or months. And a lot of the time, they will involve men cowering in their trenches from shellfire before the whistle or the bugle goes and they have to go over the top.
哦，那太美妙了。这意味着现在的战斗性质发生了根本性的变化。100年前的滑铁卢战役，基本上在一天内就尘埃落定了。但这种情况绝不可能再次发生了。这些战斗将持续数周甚至数月。而且很多时候，它们会让士兵们在炮火下瑟瑟发抖地躲在战壕里，直到哨声或军号吹响，他们不得不冲出战壕。
So this is actually the third element of the First World War that is different from other wars, maybe not the American Civil War. And it's a sense that this will never, ever end. It's a sense of interminable hopelessness. so now you have men the scenes for the first time they're pouring with rain men are knee deep in mud
所以这其实是一战区别于其他战争的第三个要素，也许美国内战除外。这是一种战争将永远永远不会结束的感觉。这是一种无休止的绝望感。所以现在你看到士兵们——头一次看到这样的场景——大雨倾盆，士兵们深陷齐膝的泥潭中
they're covered in dirt they're hungry they're exhausted the British we mentioned what they're wearing the British have been wearing the same clothes since the Battle of Mons they haven't changed in all that time it's a lot of pubic lice almost certainly
他们浑身是泥，又饿又累。我们提到英国人穿的衣服，英国人自蒙斯战役以来就一直穿着同一套衣服，这么长时间都没有换过。那上面几乎肯定有很多阴虱。
and the weird thing is even though they're not moving they're still losing 2,000 men a day killed and wounded so they're just sitting there and they're just being pummeled by shellfire and of course it's the same for all sides. There's a quote, I can't remember which book this was in.
奇怪的是，尽管他们没有移动，每天仍然有2000人伤亡。所以他们只是坐在那里，遭受着炮火的猛烈轰击。当然，各方都是如此。有一句名言，我不记得是在哪本书里看到的了。
Maybe Max Hastings. Creston Anderson, a German soldier. He writes his diary on the 28th of September. We all know we're on our way into the jaws of hell. We aren't ourselves. We're hardly human any longer. At most, we're well-drilled automaton's. God, if only we could become human again.
也许是马克斯·黑斯廷斯的书。克雷斯顿·安德森，一名德国士兵。他在9月28日的日记中写道：我们都知道我们正在走向地狱之口。我们不再是我们自己了。我们几乎不再是人类了。充其量，我们只是训练有素的自动机器。天哪，要是我们能重新变成人就好了。
And he never did. He was killed two years later at the Battle of the Somme. And that's the kind of sentiment I think you see a lot in the First World War. but you didn't see it so much in other wars where every day is different. There's a tremendous variety. You're kind of riding or marching about. And there's a sense that, who knows, the war could end next week. This time, I think everybody knows this is not going to be over anytime soon.
而他再也没有变回过。两年后他在索姆河战役中阵亡。我认为这种情绪在一战中很常见。但在其他战争中却不那么常见，在其他战争中每天都是不同的。有极大的变数。你在四处骑马或行军。并且有一种感觉，谁知道呢，战争可能下周就结束了。这一次，我想每个人都知道这不会很快结束。
So the issue for both sides is how on earth you break this deadlock now, now that you started digging in. And this is the one thing that Schlefen had feared. It was the reason he had dreamed up his plan. And from this point onwards, I think the story of the war is both sides, we've come out of various wheezes, gas, massive kind of frontal attacks, tanks, all of these different things, to try to break the deadlock. But there is just one last chance that the Germans could snatch victory before Christmas. Because by mid-September, the trenches stretch all the way. south-east of the border with Switzerland. Okay, and they stop there, do they?
所以对双方来说，问题在于，既然已经开始构筑工事，究竟该如何打破这个僵局。这也是施里芬曾经最害怕的事情。这也是他构想出那个计划的原因。从这一点开始，我认为战争的故事就是双方不断想出各种新奇的招数——毒气、大规模的正面进攻、坦克，所有这些不同的东西——试图打破僵局。但德国人其实还有最后一次机会，在圣诞节前夺取胜利。因为到9月中旬，战壕一直延伸到与瑞士接壤的东南边境。好的，它们在那里停下来了吗？
Yes. So why don't the Germans do what they've done to Belgium and go through Switzerland? The Swiss, you can't underestimate the Swiss, I think. A crack at the Swiss? A crack at the Swiss? That's the great question of history. Why has nobody ever had a crack at the Swiss? I don't know.
是的。那么德国人为什么不效仿他们对付比利时那样，穿过瑞士呢？瑞士人，你不能低估瑞士人，我是这么认为的。对瑞士人下手？对瑞士人下手？这是历史上的一个巨大谜题。为什么从来没有人对瑞士人下手？我不知道。
Maybe a Swiss listeners, if we've got any Swiss listeners, they'll be able to explain. Don't they all do military service? Yeah, they do, but I'm just thinking, you know, the Germans could just say, you know, like they did with Belton. We're really sorry. We've just got to go around the corner. But I think it's actually hard to go through Switzerland, isn't it? I mean, it's not like flat with loads of railways. I mean, although they have very good railways in Switzerland,
也许有瑞士听众，如果我们有任何瑞士听众的话，他们能够解释一下。他们不是都要服兵役吗？是的，他们确实要服兵役，但我在想，你知道的，德国人可以就像对付比利时那样说：我们真的很抱歉，我们只是得绕个弯。但我觉得穿过瑞士其实很难，对吧？我的意思是，它不像那样平坦，布满铁路。我的意思是，尽管他们在瑞士有很好的铁路，
but I think they're built for tourists rather than built for kind of a million men. Well, I just straight it out as an interesting question. Crikey. That's just not an angle I've ever. So in all those books on the First World War, I've never seen anybody, you know, Max Hastings, all these great scholars. Yeah, well, they haven't got my grasp on the operational level. That's what it is. Clearly not. Well, anyway, the trenches stretch all the way to this board, and you can't go beyond that. It's off limits.
但我认为它们是为了游客修建的，而不是为了运送数百万士兵而修建的。好吧，我只是把它作为一个有趣的问题提出来。天哪。这真是一个我从未想过的角度。所以，在所有关于第一次世界大战的书籍中，我从来没见过任何人——比如马克斯·黑斯廷斯，所有这些伟大的学者。是的，好吧，他们没有我对作战层面的把握。这就是原因。显然没有。好吧，无论如何，战壕一直延伸到这条边界，你不能超越它。那是禁区。
That's the rule. Yeah. But above the River Ane, right, there is a 170-mile space to the channel. If you could reach that, if you could go up around the trenches through this space, you could outflank your opponents. And then maybe, you know, who knows? You could get into their rear and cause all kinds of carnage. So for two months, for the next two months, through is what is called the race to the sea.
这就是规则。是的。但是在埃纳河上方，对吧，到海峡之间有一百七十英里的空隙。如果你能到达那里，如果你能通过这个空隙绕过战壕，你就能迂回包抄你的对手。然后也许，谁知道呢，你可以进入他们的后方并造成各种各样的杀戮。因此，在接下来的两个月里，通过所谓的“奔向大海”运动。
And the Germans are launching assault after assault going over further and further north trying to break through. And the Allies are kind of catching up with them. They're kind of keeping pace with each other as they're going further north. And they're sort of pushing them back. And so some of these battlefields, Albert, Arras, Tipval, Messine, they become very famous kind of first world war names. And by mid-October, this race to the sea has come down to the last bit of open territory.
德国人不断发动进攻，向更远的北方推进，试图突破。而盟军则在追赶他们。随着他们向北推进，双方保持着同步。他们某种程度上在把对方击退。因此，其中一些战场——阿尔贝、阿拉斯、蒂普瓦尔、梅森——成为了非常著名的第一次世界大战的地名。到10月中旬，这场“奔向大海”的运动已经推进到了最后一块开阔地带。
And these are the fields, the flat fields of flound. just south of the channel. And there's one town in particular that represents the last hope of a German breakthrough. It's a medieval town. It's just inside the Belgian border. It's just 20 miles from the sea. And its name, Tom, will become synonymous with the First World War because this town is Ypres. Okay.
这些就是法兰德斯的平原，就在海峡的正南方。有一个小镇特别代表着德国人实现突破的最后希望。这是一个中世纪小镇。它就在比利时边境之内。距离大海只有20英里。它的名字，汤姆，将成为第一次世界大战的代名词，因为这个小镇就是伊珀尔。好的。
So in our next episode, we will turn to the struggle for Ypres, an extraordinary story of heroism but also of horror and we will also be exploring one of the most controversial stories of the entire First World War it reverberates into the Nazi period the Kindermort, the Massacre of the Innocence and members of the Rest of History Club, of course, can hear that episode as well as the next two episodes of this series,
所以在我们的下一集里，我们将转向争夺伊珀尔的战斗，这是一段非凡的英雄主义故事，但也是一战中恐怖的故事；我们还将探讨整个一战中最具争议的故事之一，它甚至影响到了纳粹时期——德国儿童烈士之役（Kindermort），对无辜者的屠杀。“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员当然可以收听那一集以及本系列的接下来两集，
the concluding episodes right now and if you're not a member, of course you can sign up at the rest is history.com. Goodbye. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
即最终的几集。如果你还不是会员，当然可以在therestisistory.com注册。再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。